être particulièrement attendue pour
éclaircir l'ensemble de ces points
avant de vous céder la parole si vous le
souhaitez bien sûr pour un bref propos
introductif je dois vous rappeler qu'un
faux témoignage devant une commission
d'enquête et passible de sanctions
pénale qui peuvent aller selon les
circonstances de 3 à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 à 100.000
euros d'amende je vous invite à prêter
ce monde de dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité levait la main droite il
dit je le jure
merci je vous laisse donc à présent la
parole pour un bref
introduction s'il vous plaît merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs je serai bref
mais je veux d'abord bien évidemment
vous remercier de cette audition devant
à la mission d'information devant cette
commission d'enquête je vais tâcher
humblement et dans la limite bien sûr
des éléments dont je dispose de vous
aider à établir une chronologie mais
aussi la matérialité des faits vu de ma
fenêtre c'est à dire la fenêtre du
ministre et donc je suis heureuse de
pouvoir répondre pour la première fois
un certain nombre de questions
particulières en dehors du bruit ou des
commentaires ou des supputations qui ont
pu être émises en dehors bien sûr de
cette commission et tout de pouvoir être
aussi factuel que possible donc je vais
tâcher de vous aider en cela je reste
sans doute pas réponse à tout je me suis
pas omnisciente sur ce sujet ni sur les
autres d'ailleurs
mais les enseignements et la maternité
de certains faits eu égard au travail du
rapport de l'IGA nous nous aiderons
j'imagine en cela je vais vous dire
d'ores et déjà monsieur le Président et
monsieur le rapporteur que vous m'avez
écrit hier soir pour me demander d'avoir
accès aux archives des mails échangés
entre mon cabinet et moi-même bien
évidemment je donne mon accord pour que
vous puissiez avoir accès à ces archives
donc je vous fais une réponse écrite qui
va vous parvenir là aujourd'hui et qui
vous permettra d'avoir accès à
l'ensemble de ces messages bien
évidemment je veux très brièvement
rappeler le rôle de chacun de manière
habituelle dans un fonctionnement
ministériel vous avez le ministre qui
impulse des politiques publiques
qui représentent également ces
politiques publiques qui en est
comptable devant bien sûr le Parlement
je suis là aujourd'hui mais devant tous
les exercices que vous connaissez devant
le Parlement mais aussi devant les
citoyens soit de manière directe soit de
manière indirecte par on va dire des
médias c'est le rôle du ministre le rôle
de l'administration c'est la mise en
œuvre de ces politiques publiques
impulsées par le ministre la mise en
oeuvre et le suivi et le ministre en
cela s'appuie sur la confiance qu'il a
dans les collaborateurs ce qu'il a
choisi ou ceux qui l'a trouvé en
arrivant et s'appuie sur la sincérité
des déclarations des rapports mais aussi
des comptes fait par les partenaires et
par les associations brièvement
peut-être remettre le contexte de la
création de ce fond Marianne même si
j'imagine que nous y reviendrons je veux
rappeler que le contexte c'est celui de
ce que certains experts dont Gilles
Keppel notamment appellent le djihadisme
d'atmosphère ça veut dire que des
terroristes désormais ne se radicalisent
plus en allant dans des endroits comme
précédemment certains dans certains
kebab ou certaines mosquées qui étaient
radicalisées qui étaient des lieux
d'endoctrinement mais ce radicalisent
sur internet en consultant des sites des
plateformes ou des réseaux sociaux dans
le contexte les spécialistes
recommandent de lutter contre ce terreau
du terrorisme en allant là où ce
discours se portent c'est à dire en
ligne sur les réseaux sociaux et il est
donc décidé en ce qui nous concerne par
une décision du Conseil de défense de
faire appel notamment à des acteurs de
la société civile pour soutenir ce
discours républicain comme ça se fait
dans d'autres pays comme le Royaume-Uni
et le fond Marianne il s'inscrit dans
cette action globale ce n'est pas je
tiens à dire l'entièreté de la politique
publique menée pour lutter contre la
radicalisation je veux le rappeler il y
a une politique plus globale je vous en
fais pas la liste exhaustive mais
simplement mentionner l'ucdr dont on
parlera peut-être la lutte contre la
haine en ligne l'ouverture de farose 24
heures sur 24 et les dispositions
législatives que vous connaissez
parfaitement pour en tant que
parlementaire les avoir nourris ou en
tout cas avoir pris part au débat je
veux dire aussi mais j'imagine que nous
y reviendrons que le budget du fond
Marianne
est une ligne budgétaire du FIPD donc du
ministère de l'Intérieur je sais que
vous le savez mais je tiens à être
factuel dans ce propos liminaire bref ce
n'est à aucun moment une cagnotte je
l'ai entendu ici et là l'état bien
évidemment ne lance pas de cagnotte au
profit des familles de victimes de
terrorisme il n'y a pas de cagnotte il
n'y a pas de collecte de fonds c'est une
ligne budgétaire du ministère de
l'intérieur et en l'espèce du FIP des
je veux dire également que il y a des
questions aujourd'hui très légitimes qui
se posent et je salue j'avais appelé de
mes vœux dans le respect de la
séparation des pouvoirs l'ouverture de
cette commission d'enquête je la salue
et je m'en réjouis parce qu'elle permet
justement par des auditions longues
précises par des témoignages parfois par
la mise en lumière de contradiction
d'avérer un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements le rapport de l'igéa
d'ailleurs commandé à la demande du
gouvernement et réalisé au ministère de
l'Intérieur il met en oeuvre il met en
lumière pardon des dysfonctionnements
qui sont avérés qui sont documentés et
nous allons je pense y revenir mais je
veux dire ici qu'il y a je profite de ce
trop polymère pour le dire il y a aussi
il y a surtout dans leur grande majorité
des associations qui mènent un travail
remarquable pour défendre la laïcité
pour lutter contre l'islamisme la
radicalisation ou les discours dit
séparatiste de manière globale
aujourd'hui beaucoup des acteurs du fond
qui sont des associations que vous avez
pu auditionner donc vous avez pu
constater le sérieux pour la grande
majorité d'entre elles sont brocardées
insultés pour certaines même menacées de
morts comme beaucoup d'acteurs qui
s'engagent contre la radicalisation
contre l'islamisme et je veux dire ici
mon soutien à ces associations et à ces
personnalités qui s'engagent et
également aux agents du cipdr passé et
actuels qui dans leur immense majorité
mène au ministère de l'Intérieur un
travail difficile avec avec beaucoup de
sérieux pour conclure je voudrais dire
que votre votre retour d'expérience et
les recommandations j'imagine que vous
formulerez à l'issue de cette commission
d'enquête seront particulièrement
intéressants bien évidemment pour chacun
en tant que citoyen pour moi en tant que
secrétaire d'État qui à ce jour suit
chargé de la vie associative ce que vous
direz sur la manière dont on doit ou ne
doit pas attribuer des subventions par
exemple aux associations sur la jusqu'où
on doit aller dans le contrôle de
l'attribution des subventions ce sera
extrêmement intéressant je disais pour
moi en tant que que membre du
gouvernement mais aussi je pense pour
tous les décideurs publics parce que les
décisions en tout cas les
recommandations qui seront les
enseignements en tout cas qui seront
tirés à l'issue de cette commission
d'enquête et bien elle poseront des
questions
que je pose et auxquelles je n'ai pas
forcément la réponse mais demain est-ce
qu'un décideur public est-ce qu'un
responsable politique est-ce qu'un maire
par exemple peut faire confiance à son
administration ou à des associations
sans craindre d'être blâmé lorsqu'il y a
des dysfonctionnements internes à ces
associations est-ce qu'un responsable
politique est fondé à passer des
commandes à son administration et plus
important encore dirais-je que cela
demain comment peut-on poursuivre cette
politique publique nécessaire de lutte
contre la radicalisation et contre le
terreau du sans que la peur d'être
amalgamé à ce dossier
désormais dit du fond Marianne puisse
exister je veux dire pour conclure que
cette politique publique en ce qui
concerne le gouvernement puisque je suis
auditionnée à ce titre et bien elle se
poursuit je n'en suis plus en charge
depuis plus d'un an j'ai tout confiance
dans mes successeur mais aussi dans
l'administration telle qu'elle est
constituée actuellement et dans
l'ensemble des parties prenantes pour
continuer à mener ce combat qui est un
combat essentiel nécessaire à notre pays
et qui est un maillon de la chaîne de la
lutte contre la radicalisation et le
terrorisme mais qui est je crois un
maillon essentiel qui doit absolument
perdurer je suis à votre entière
disposition pour répondre à toutes vos
questions je vous remercie merci merci
madame la ministre d'avoir tenu un
propos relativement court en
introduction je donne la parole tout de
suite au rapporteur
à propos qu'on en sait en effet merci
madame la ministre vous avez évoqué dans
votre propos introductif interne en tous
les cas qui n'a jamais été utilisé dans
notre commission le terme de cagnotte
je pense qu'il n'a pas sa raison d'être
qu'il n'y ait aucune ambiguïté et je
vais en profiter puisque vous avez donné
quelques explications sur le
fonctionnement du fond
il n'a pas échappé évidemment aux
membres de la commission des finances
réunies en commission d'information
commission d'enquête et peut-être dire
quelques mots à l'attention de celles et
ceux qui nous écoutent vous l'avez dit
il y a aujourd'hui trois procédures sur
le dossier je vais l'appeler comme ça
du fond Marianne il y a une procédure en
cours avec un rapport partiel de
l'inspection générale de
l'administration il y a une procédure
une ouverture
d'une information du judiciaire par le
parquet national financiers et puis une
commission d'enquête dont je rappelle
que elle est la forme la plus élaborée
du contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
qui est ouverte au Parlement et à
chacune de ces assemblées et pour être
parfaitement clair et que chacun
se rappelle à la fois le principe de la
séparation des pouvoirs mais justement
fort de ce principe la liberté donnée à
chacun dans cette responsabilité sous
l'autorité de notre prêt dans la
commission des finances nous avions
saisi le garde des sceaux pour nous
assurer de la compatibilité des
différentes démarches raison pour
laquelle le dossier évidemment se
poursuit et je vais tout de suite
rentrer dans le vif du sujet notamment
vous l'avez dit sur le fond Marianne qui
n'est que un montant relativement peu
élevé globalement par rapport au FIPD je
voulais d'abord pour commencer
revenir puisqu'on connaît le contexte
dans lequel se font a été créé
c'est peut-être un point de détail mais
pas nécessairement qu'est-ce qui a
présidé à ce choix du fond Marianne qui
la définit comment avez-vous procédé
merci à monsieur le rapporteur d'abord
pour être très clair vis-à-vis de votre
propos introductif à vous-même enfin si
j'ai bien compris je n'ai à aucun moment
remis en cause l'existence de la
commission c'est pas moi que ça
s'adressait très bien d'accord
on n'a pas le même niveau d'information
très bien je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur alors le fond Marianne je
vous le disais en conseil de défense il
y a une décision qui est prise de faire
appel et de mobiliser les acteurs de ce
qu'on appelle alors contre discours
républicain je comprends que cette
appellation porte à différentes
appréciations mais en tout cas c'est
l'appellation qui lui est donné à ce
moment là ou en tout cas de porter un
discours en défense des valeurs de la
République en ligne cette décision est
prise un certain nombre d'acteurs de la
société civile sont mobilisées pour
faire en sorte justement de mettre en
œuvre cette décision
et nous avons avec mon directeur de
cabinet Monsieur le Préfet jalelet que
vous avez auditionné nous nous
bénéficions il m'informe du fait que
nous avons obtenu un arbitrage favorable
de Matignon pour reporter des crédits
non utilisés du FIPD de l'année
précédente donc la ligne budgétaire du
fond interministériel de prévention de
la délinquance et de la radicalisation
même donc du fipdr nous bénéficions
d'après les éléments dont je dispose il
m'envoie un message pour dire que nous
bénéficions de 2 millions et demi
d'euros de reports de crédit et donc
comme nous avons à la fois une
demande de mobiliser les acteurs de la
société civile pour porter ce discours
et cette ligne budgétaire dont nous
bénéficions nous décidons pour plus de
lisibilité de mettre en oeuvre une
appellation de fond Marianne qui
regroupe
sous le biais d'un appel à projet d'un
AAP ces acteurs de la société civile que
le ministère viendrait soutenir dans
leur action de discours républicains
donc le nom de Marianne est simplement
un écho au symbole de la République
alors plusieurs choses d'abord le nom
Marianne c'est j'apprends à personne
c'est l'allégorie de la République un
panneau Marianne au Sénat à l'entrée une
exposition sur la figure de Marianne
c'est une figure qu'on utilise
traditionnellement au ministère de
l'Intérieur je ne lançais plusieurs
projets qui ont le non Marianne comme
les 109 Mariannes ou les Mariannes de la
République et peut-être d'autres je suis
pas la seule le nom et couramment usité
c'était un nom par ailleurs qui était
important pour le cipdr qui avait un
moment le projet de lancer des réseaux
sociaux marianne.gouv et finalement le
nom république.gouv avait été retenu
mais on avait dans mes souvenirs en tout
cas j'en ai pas trace écrite mais dans
mes souvenirs il y a un consensus sur le
fait que quand on dit Marianne chacun
comprend qu'il s'agit de la République
et de défendre les valeurs de la
République c'est en tout cas comme ça
que je me souviens de ces échanges merci
vous avez évoqué à deux reprises avoir
fait le choix d'un sur le montant d'un
appel à projet pour ouvrir aux
partenariat avec le réseau associatif
pourquoi avoir eu recours un appel à
projet sachant que vous avez déjà des
acteurs implantés qui ont un
savoir-faire comment vous êtes-vous tenu
informé du processus et à quelles étapes
êtes-vous
intervenus pour obtenir des retours
d'information ou pour valider des
décisions
alors d'abord monsieur le rapporteur sur
le choix de l'appel à projet il y a un
échange entre mon directeur de cabinet
monsieur préfet j'allais et moi-même sur
la manière justement de financer et de
soutenir financièrement au mieux les
acteurs de la société civile Monsieur le
Préfet j'allais me propose de passer par
un appel à projet en me disant tout à
fait conscient qu'aujourd'hui ça peut
paraître paradoxal à la lumière des
événements mais en disant que ce sera
plus transparent et plus équitable que
les subventions de gré à gré puisque
jusqu'à présent c'était des subventions
me semble-t-il de gré à gré du cipdr en
direction des associations nous avons
alors le sentiment que l'appel à projet
répond effectivement à cette demande
d'une part d'autre part qui permettra de
faire émerger de nouveaux acteurs qui
sont pas forcément encore
identifiés dans la sphère du cipdr et
donc nous prenons ensemble et j'assume
la décision de passer par un appel à
projet
ensuite il y a un comité de sélection
qui est mise en place avec des membres
de l'administration et des membres de
mon cabinet moi je n'interviens pas
personnellement je ne suis pas dans le
comité de sélection eu égard ce que je
rappelais dans mon propos introductifs
les rôles de chacun mais pas du rôle du
ministre de faire de l'hymne générique
et d'ouvrir le capot pour regarder
l'ensemble des dossiers donc je ne suis
pas dans le comité de sélection en
revanche je suis tenue bien sûr informé
régulièrement par mon cabinet des
discussions qui peuvent exister autour
de l'attribution des subventions
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir mais à ma connaissance
vous deviez faire partie du comité de
sélection je n'en ai pas souvenir je
n'ai pas de trace dans mes éléments du
fait que je dois en faire partie en tout
cas je n'en fais pas partie c'est une
observation que je porte à la
connaissance de chacun
je relève dans l'explication que vous
venez de donner que vous avez vous dites
avoir suivi des conseils du préfet
Jallet votre directeur de cabinet à
l'époque
et vous dites pour l'appel à projet
étant considéré comme une procédure plus
transparente et plus équitable je mesure
que vous utilisez à dessin ces mots
puisque ce sont exactement les mêmes qui
sont repris par l'Inspection générale de
l'administration pour
dénoncer le fait que la procédure était
ni transparente ni équitable donc je ne
sais pas si c'est un une manière pour
vous de répondre et de dire que il y a
eu erreur sur toute la ligne je sais pas
si vous voulez
aller un peu plus loin sur le sujet
parce que si vous démarrez vos propos en
expliquant que ce qui devait être plus
juste plus transparent et plus équitable
ne l'est pas de votre propre aveu enfin
déclaration et donc aveu c'est une
déclaration me semble-t-il importante
que vous faites à cet instant
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit d'abord moi
je n'ai pas d'appréciation à porter sur
le rapport de l'ijia c'est un rapport
qui a été mené avec le plus grand
sérieux par une inspection qui est
réputée pour son professionnalisme qui a
eu accès à des informations auxquelles
moi je n'ai pas accès puisque une fois
encore je ne suis pas omnisciente dans
ce dossier j'étais ministre dans un
temps donné dans un temps limité je n'ai
pas interrogé les différents acteurs
c'est l'hygia qui a réalisé ce travail
mais je n'ai aucune raison de de
contester la conclusion de l'hygia et je
n'ai non plus je me paraît de reprendre
votre terme ce rapport aucun aveu à
faire dans la mesure où je n'ai pas pris
à ce comité pas pris part pardon à ce
comité de sélection
d'accord
en audition il nous a été indiqué
qu'avec votre arrivée en poste le 6
juillet 2020 le processus de décision du
moins pour l'attribution de certaines
subventions du FIPD
était passé en fait du secrétaire
général du
cipdr au cabinet au motif ce qui est en
audition que le périmètre de votre
ministère du secrétariat d'État était
parfaitement
identique à celui du cpdr ce qui voulait
dire que la signature le pouvoir de
décision
sortait des mains de l'administration
pour être aux mains exclusives du
pouvoir politique
comment expliquer vous ce changement
qu'elles en sont les motivations et
finalement qui participait concrètement
autour de vous avec vous au processus de
décision
je ne dirais pas du tout que les
décisions étaient remises exclusivement
aux mains du pouvoir politique et je ne
dirais pas non plus si vous me le
permettez que c'est parce que le
périmètre du ministère cadré avec le
périmètre du cipdr le périmètre du
ministère délégué était bien plus large
que celui du cpdr avec notamment la
question de l'intégration des étrangers
de l'accélération des délais pour les
cartes d'identité et beaucoup d'autres
missions en dehors du cpdr en revanche
ce qui est juste c'est que avec la
création d'un ministère délégué à la
citoyenneté pour la première fois un
ministre a autorité sur le cipdr qui
auparavant était interministériel et
donc n'avait pas me semble-t-il de
ministre de tutelle pour la première
fois me semble-t-il dans un décret
d'attribution c'est le cas et donc c'est
pour cette raison que c'est remontées au
niveau du cabinet pour des validations
mais ça ne veut pas dire que que le
cipdr est dépossédé de son pouvoir de
décision les éléments le démontrent
d'ailleurs on a effectivement des
nouvelles priorités politiques à cet
égard donc beaucoup sont concentrés au
cpdr la lutte contre les dérives
sectaires la montée en puissance des ISG
qui sont gérés par le cipdr la question
de la lutte contre le cyber islamisme
qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui il y a un
processus calé par le directeur de
cabinet l'administration elle instruit
et elle propose et l'autorité
ministérielle valide ce qui a été
instruit et proposé par l'administration
à mon humble avis c'est un procédé
classique il y a des réunions qui
existent avec le secrétaire général et
des réunions hebdomadaires entre le
lgcipdr
équivalent directeur d'administration et
le directeur de cabinet à ma
connaissance ce procédé est maintenu
d'ailleurs par ma successeur madame la
ministre bacaisse qui vous confirmera ou
pas enfin en tout cas s'exprimera sur ce
sujet tout à l'heure
oui donc
votre propos
confirme l'observation que j'ai
prononcer dans ma question
vous l'avez dit le pouvoir politique
c'est-à-dire le ministre
est où son directeur de cabinet on le
pouvoir de décider et de signer et
l'administration vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs dans votre couple introductif
met en œuvre mais le périmètre est en
conforme à celui de votre ministère et
non plus sous l'Internet ministériel ça
vous donne les pleins pouvoirs de
décision ça paraît de ce côté là un
discutable monsieur le rapporteur le ni
le
le cabinet ne signe d'attribution de
subventions puisque c'est la question
qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui à aucun
moment ni le ministre ni le cabinet ne
met en paiement des crédits ou ne signe
d'échec c'est la prérogative de
l'administration et à aucun moment nous
n'avons ni la volonté ni même le pouvoir
matériel de le faire donc je suis claire
sur ce sujet je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir parce que il y a
manifestement des zones de conflits
entre les auditions et entre les
comment dire j'ai déclarations des uns
et des autres
à ce stade une dernière question vous
avez annoncé
le 31 mars 2021 la suppression de
l'Observatoire de la laïcité soit
quelques jours avant l'annonce le 20
avril de la création du fond Marianne et
à l'époque le gouvernement avait fait
l'objet de critique parfois assez vive
considérant qu'il était porteur d'une
vision très centralisée de la laïcité et
je cite évitant d'avoir une pluralité de
voix à l'intérieur de l'espace public
le fond Marianne s'inscrivait-il dans
cette logique visant à avoir un message
plutôt unique voire unitaire autour et
donc cohérent sur la laïcité et
notamment en prévoyant de
contractualiser avec des associations
s'inscrivant dans cette cohérence de la
parole
durée assez unitaire du gouvernement
mais cela rapporteur s'agissant de
l'Observatoire de la laïcité l'annonce a
été faite par Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de l'époque à Monsieur le
Premier Ministre Jean Castex auprès de
qui l'Observatoire de la laïcité était
rattachée parce que c'est une
organisation qui dépendait de Matignon
qui est une organisation qui a produit
de nombreux rapports et qui a fait un
travail d'observation de la laïcité et y
compris de contribution au débat public
qui est un apport important qui je crois
n'a pas été contestée ou remis en cause
en tout cas dans la qualité des rapports
et du travail mené par cette
organisation
plurielle pour reprendre votre
expression c'est donc le premier
ministre qui annonce le fait que le
gouvernement met fin à l'Observatoire de
la laïcité non pas sur une question de
désaccord de ligne mais à ma
connaissance parce que nous entendons
passer à un autre mode d'action vous
aviez un observatoire qui donc observait
produisait des rapports ou des
recommandations et nous avons souhaité
avec Monsieur le Premier Ministre de
l'époque
créé non seulement un comité
interministériel à la laïcité qui soit
chargée de la réflexion et de
l'impulsion d'action concrète et de
politique publique portée par le
gouvernement sur la question de la
laïcité mais aussi d'un bureau de la
laïcité il n'y en avait pas précédemment
au ministère de l'Intérieur il y avait
un bureau déculte il n'y avait pas de
bureau de la laïcité et donc nous
l'avons créé afin de faire en sorte de
passer si vous permettez l'expression de
l'observation à l'action en la matière
et à la possibilité de coordonner les
actions menées en matière de laïcité
donc je vais redire parce que c'est ce
que je mettais noté vous choisissez
après avoir observé une manière
convergente à vous entendre à l'action
donc la capacité à agir si j'ai bien
compris votre propos à l'instant tout à
fait dans l'esprit des travaux de
l'observatoire et donc
le même esprit fort de la volonté d'agir
au regard des événements
consécutifs à l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty
mais je ne crois absolument pas qu'il
n'y ait aucun acteur membre de
l'Observatoire de la laïcité qui
souhaite ne pas agir manque de
l'ancienne observatoire de la laïcité
qui souhaite ne pas agir face au
terrorisme je n'ai jamais dit cela et je
ne le crois pas
ne vous méprenez pas j'ai pas du tout
mis en doute je dis j'essaie simplement
votre question
on observe on agit il est mis fin à
l'observatoire je veux juste m'assurer
c'était le sens de ma question que la
volonté d'agir elle s'inscrit dans le
droit fil des travaux de l'observatoire
et du nouveau contexte c'est uniquement
le sens de ma question très sincèrement
est en sincèrement je peux pas me
prononcer sur l'intégralité des rapports
émis pendant des années par
l'Observatoire de la laïcité n'ayant les
ayant pas là sous les yeux avec moi
enfin il y a pas de
si si c'est bien la question mais je
suis sûr d'avoir compris votre question
mais si c'est la question en tout cas
c'est la réponse
c'est donc ma réponse de toute façon
des sujets que nous avons évoqué mais un
peu plus dans le dans le détail pour
valider ou pas les positions que vous
avez exprimé
alors je vais changer de registre et on
va venir directement sur sur le dossier
le sans doute le plus compliqué qui a
donné lieu d'ailleurs à un rapport
d'abord à part si je peux dire d'un
inspection générale de l'administration
en lui mettant en lumière en certain
nombre de difficultés et dans des termes
que je qualifierais d'extrêmement dur
et donc on va on va venir tout de suite
son système de points très très précis
donc premier point c'est les les
contacts Monsieur Mohamed cifaoui avant
mars 2021
et puis j'allais dire avant votre entrée
en fonction puis après votre entrée en
fonction
donc dans quel contexte vous êtes connu
et quels ont été vos échanges et si vous
voulez bien le détailler justement avant
votre entrée en fonction s'il y en a eu
puis après votre en fonction et puis on
arrivera évidemment sur sur le début
des discussions sur le fond Marianne
bien entendu mais j'y reviendrai plus
précisément d'abord le contexte
concernant le contexte d'abord peut-être
de de l'association et puis ensuite de
Monsieur Sifaoui si ça vous convient
d'abord sur la question de l'ucpm
j'observe que le rapport effectivement
de l'igéa qui est dur mais qui est
factuel me semble-t-il qui est documenté
par des je vous interdire si vous voulez
on viendra vers l'association après
parce que on a bien compris que
l'association elle arrivait dans un
deuxième temps
très proche d'ailleurs de la réponse au
fond Marianne donc dans un premier temps
ou avez-vous rencontré Monsieur
voilà je vous remercie pour votre
question monsieur le Président qui va me
permettre je l'espère de clarifier un
certain nombre de choses je j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire mais je le dis et
sous serment et dans ce contexte et face
à cette commission je ne suis pas une
amie de Monsieur Sifaoui et je le dis
parce que dans un premier temps c'est ce
qui a été rapporté et c'est ce qui a été
dit je le dément il est
difficile de démontrer qu'on n'est pas
ami avec quelqu'un si on dit je ne suis
pas amie et qu'en face on nous dit si
vous êtes amis monsieur CIFA oui
lui-même s'est exprimé sur BFM TV et a
dit également je ne suis pas un ami de
Madame Schiappa
le terme ami est un mot-valise
personnel je vais éliminer les
hypothèses une par une monsieur le
Président
qui est la laïcité voilà je vais
éliminer une par une monsieur le
Président si vous me le permettez toutes
ces hypothèses je ne suis pas une amie
de Monsieur cifaoui je n'ai aucune
relation personnelle d'aucune sorte avec
Monsieur cifaoui et je n'en ai jamais eu
je ne suis pas avec Monsieur cifaoui
membre de même organisations nous ne
nous retrouvons pas dans tel ou tel
association ou organisation en dehors de
mon action ministérielle je n'ai pas
l'occasion de rencontrer Monsieur
cifaoui dans aucun lieu privé ni chez
lui ni chez moi ni dans une activité
sportive et je peux vous faire
l'intégralité de la liste je ne connais
pas sa vie personnelle ni sa famille il
connaît pas la mienne bref nous ne
sommes pas amis nous ne sommes pas dans
sans associés nous n'avons pas d'intérêt
commun et nous ne sommes ensemble
la connaissance membre d'aucune
organisation puisque c'est aussi le
sous-jacent de pas de vous monsieur le
Président mais de certaines formulations
qui ont été faites moi monsieur cifaoui
je le vois à plusieurs reprises et pas
en tête à tête et je tiens à le dire ici
parce que l'un des témoignages qui a été
apportés devant votre commission à
affirmer que j'aurai reçu
personnellement en tête-à-tête monsieur
Sifaoui au mois de mars et que ce serait
à cette occasion que je lui aurais
annoncé qu'il aurait une subvention ou
qu'il serait éligible au fond Marianne
c'est faux
c'est faux je tiens à le dire ici sous
serment c'est faux je le dis et c'est
documenté par l'ensemble de mon agenda
et des échanges de messages avec mon
cabinet j'ai un message d'un de mes
conseillers dater environ du 20 avril
peu ouproux qui d'ailleurs m'interpelle
en me disant que je n'ai pas rencontré
Monsieur Sifaoui et de mémoire dans son
mail il dit vous devriez rencontrer
recevoir Monsieur cifaoui donc moi j'ai
participé à des événements ministériels
auxquels monsieur Sifaoui était présent
notamment et je l'ai lu dans la presse
ou dans un rapport ce que j'en avais pas
souvenir j'ai fait un déplacement dans
le Tarn et Monsieur Sifaoui avait été
convié je crois à ma connaissance par le
sgcpdr pour délivrer une formation à
cette occasion nous ne sommes pas je
n'ai pas moi congé monsieur Sifaoui à
venir j'étais présente et il était
présent il est intervenu également il a
également participé à une
visioconférence avec d'autres experts
que je peux citer si vous le souhaitez
dans le cadre des travaux préparatoires
à la loi séparatiste puisqu'il était un
interlocuteur du cipdr monsieur cifaoui
était en lien avec le cpdr longtemps
avant ma propre nomination il y a des
comptes-rendus qui sont dans les
dossiers qui montrent qu'il est reçu et
qu'il a des entretiens avec le cipdr ce
qui n'est pas anormal puisque c'est à ce
moment un acteur reconnu de l'écosystème
de la lutte contre l'islamisme il a
publié des ouvrages il fait des
interventions et donc il fait partie des
acteurs consultés par le cipdr mais je
tiens à être clair et formel sur le fait
que nous ne sommes pas amis nous n'avons
pas de relation personnelle et nous
n'avons pas d'intérêt commun ou
d'appartenance communes à ma
connaissance à tel ou tel organisation
j'espère avoir été clair monsieur le
Président la réponse est claire en tout
cas
a affirmé alors c'est dans le rapport de
l'IGA puisque nous n'avons pas vous le
savez pu entendre sincèrement monsieur
Sifaoui malheureusement nous sommes
décalés à demain
mais monsieur Sifaoui selon le rapport
de l'IGA a affirmé qu'il y a eu 6
réunions entre lui et votre cabinet en
mars et avril 2021 et qu'il y a eu un
échange avec vous durant deux de ces
réunions et votre directeur de cabinet a
dit que c'était en fait qui est venu le
saluer cursivement donc
voilà donc vous nous direz
qu'elles ont pu être les échanges à ce
moment-là que vous avez eu avec Monsieur
cifaoui si vous le voulez bien et si
vous en souvenez avec précision et le
cas échéant bien sûr si cela est vrai je
parle des six rencontres c'est pas une
rencontre c'est pas de rencontre c'est 6
rencontres
quels étaient donc les réunions en
question et et sur quoi porter porter
les discussions
là c'est un point extrêmement important
vous le comprenez
juste je le remets dans un peu dans la
chronologie des faits puisque nous
sommes là avant avant même l'appel
d'offres Marianne
oui monsieur le Président d'abord sur
les rencontres et ce qui se dit entre
monsieur Sifaoui et mon cabinet ou
l'administration parce que je sais pas
si les six rencontrent ont lieu avec mon
cabinet et où l'administration j'ai lu
le chiffre de ces rencontres j'ai lu
d'ailleurs dans un journal a fait un
raccourci en disant que c'était si
rencontre avec moi-même j'espère qu'il
est clair aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas
le cas mais dans ces dans ces
discussions je ne sais pas monsieur le
Président je ne sais pas ce qui se dit
entre mon cabinet et Monsieur Sifa oui
je ne peux qu'imaginer qu'il parle de
lutte contre l'islamisme contre le cyber
islamisme que Monsieur Sifaoui peut-être
fait part des projets qui sont qui sont
les siens et en ce qui concerne les
moments où je vais le saluer moi j'ai
matériellement ça veut pas dire qu'il y
en a pas eu d'autres peut-être que je
suis allé le saluer et que je ne m'en
souviens pas on parle de fait il y a
quasiment deux ans mais Monsieur le
Préfet j'allais dit j'ai pas de raison
de ne pas le croire que je suis venue
saluer lors d'un rendez-vous du 22 avril
si ma mémoire est bonne monsieur Sifaoui
c'est tout à fait probable ça m'arrive
fréquemment de venir saluer de manière
par courtoisie les gens qui sont reçus
par les membres de mon cabinet je n'ai
pas souvenir monsieur le Président de ce
que j'ai pu lui dire très honnêtement au
moment de le saluer mais en tout cas si
c'est la question je ne lui ai pas dit
que j'allais lui attribuer une
subvention ou lui faire attribuer une
subvention ça je ne le fais jamais donc
c'est très clair ni même ni même
l'encourager à déposer un dossier dans
le cadre du fond Marianne alors ça très
honnêtement ce n'est pas impossible que
j'encourage des gens à déposer des
dossiers je le fais pardon monsieur le
Président mais tout le temps là je suis
aujourd'hui chargée de l'économie
sociale et solidaire dans les dernières
semaines j'ai reçu des gens qui m'ont
dit qu'ils souhaitaient pouvoir être
subventionnés et je leur ai dit je vous
encourage vivement à déposer un dossier
auprès de l'administration pour que
l'administration instruise votre dossier
et pardon de dévoiler cela mais
encourager quelqu'un à déposer un
dossier ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va le
soutenir c'est une formule générale qui
signifie aussi que on l'encourage
déposer le dossier et que le dossier
sera étudié et à renvoyer l'étude du
dossier à l'administration c'est en tout
cas comme ça que je conçois les choses
oui alors vous nous dites vous nous
dites il y a eu peut-être ces réunions
enfin en tout cas vous ne savez pas
voilà
avec votre cabinet vous dites ça vous
nous dites je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
dit entre mon cabinet je remets les mots
entre mon cabinet monsieur cifaoui
c'est la question du fond Marianne est
sur la table maintenant depuis quelques
mois
vous avez pas interrogé votre directeur
de cabinet entre-temps pour venir
préparer cette audition pour lui dire il
semblerait que vous ayez rencontré
si vous ne connaissez pas donc ça ne va
où il y a plusieurs reprises qu'est-ce
que vous avez pu dire etc nous je vous
rappelle que nous avons eu l'information
par le rapport de l'igéa c'est-à-dire
postérieurement à l'audition de Monsieur
j'allais sinon nous aurions directement
posé la question mais ce que je veux
vous dire c'est qu'il est difficile il
est difficile
d'imaginer qu'un ministre et son cabinet
ne fonctionne pas totalement en totale
totale comment dire confiance et en
totale transmission on connaît quand
même voilà on est bien les structures de
cabinet on connaît bien la manière de
travailler et je ne vois pas quand même
je peux pas imaginer un directeur de
cabinet ou un conseiller spécial de
votre la cabine est chargée de ces
questions avancer dans le cadre de 6
réunions si elles ont eu lieu les 6
puisque pour l'instant on a on n'a pas
de confirmation de votre part mais si
elles ont eu lieu ne pas avancer sans
vous faire un report un reporting tout
simplement
une note ou un propos oral mais en tout
cas sur des sujets de sa nature je
rappelle aussi madame pour bien aller au
fond de ma pensée que on est sur un
sujet sur lequel la communication votre
communication la communication du
ministère a été extrêmement forte sur un
sujet qui a été rappelé par le
rapporteur qui est encore dans tous les
esprits aujourd'hui je samedi exemple je
vais être à Toulouse à l'inauguration
d'une place ou d'une rue Samuel Paty
elle est dans tous les esprits donc si
vous voulez vous êtes sur un sujet qui
est sensible vous êtes sur une position
politique affichée et vous ne suivriez
pas
les discussions entre votre cabinet et
Monsieur cifaoui par exemple
j'ai un peu dommage donc si vous voulez
bien revenir là-dessus
bien sûr monsieur le Président
d'abord sauf erreur de ma part ce n'est
pas Monsieur le Préfet Jallet donc
directeur de cabinet à ce moment-là il
me semble qu'il reçoit monsieur Sifaoui
je pense
à vérifier sauf ça fait les mots
matériel contraire mais je pense qu'il
est reçu par l'administration et par des
membres de mon cabinet et notamment je
vous le disais dans le cadre de la
préparation de la loi dit séparatisme la
loi pour conforter les principes de la
République dans ce cadre
on est en avril 2021 on est déjà bien
après la réflexion préalable à la loi me
semble-t-il
rencontres elles n'ont pas lieu en avril
21 en fait quand on quand on relate le
fait que monsieur cifaoui a été reçu
avant le fond Marianne
moi je vous en mars et avril 2021 donc
on n'est pas sur la question de la loi
ça c'était avant qui a eu effectivement
des visios avec différents experts tout
ça tout ça est très clair alors c'est ça
que je mentionnais dans mon propos et
c'est pour ça que je j'éclairais le
thème de ces échanges à cet égard vous
l'avez très justement dit monsieur le
Président il y a une relation de
confiance entre un ministre et son
cabinet et donc moi en tout cas
peut-être que c'est une erreur mais en
tout cas c'est comme ça que je
fonctionne je ne vais pas par exemple
regarder les agendas des membres de mon
cabinet et je ne leur demande pas
quotidiennement qu'ils ont reçu ou avec
qui ils ont échangé il y a des réunions
thématiques globales et c'est à cette
occasion que du cabinet font état des
personnes qui ont vu en revanche ce que
je peux vous dire
matériellement puisque j'en ai la trace
que j'ai retrouvé j'en avais aucun
souvenir mais je l'ai retrouvé dans mes
mails et vous aurez donc accès j'ai des
membres de mon cabinet qui reçoivent
monsieur cifaoui à une reprise lorsqu'il
présente un projet il dit qu'il a un
projet de contreditours sur le cyber
islamisme et c'est à cette occasion que
mon cabinet m'adresse un mail c'est le
seul trace écrite que j'ai relative à un
rendez-vous entre des membres de mon
cabinet et Monsieur cifaoui et dans ce
mail il m'explique ce projet c'est à ce
mail d'ailleurs que je réponds puisqu'il
me détaille les montants du projet et je
réponds pardon pour la familiarité mais
c'est un échange qui a évocation à ce
moment-là je réponds ceci 300ke d'argent
de l'État pour ce projet ça me paraît
énorme ici
c'est ma réponse et je me réjouis
aujourd'hui de l'avoir répondu par écrit
parce que ça démontre bien que j'ai
trouvé que ce projet était trop coûteux
on me demande mon premier avis mon
conseiller dans une discussion
informelle me parle d'un projet ma
première réponse et mon impulsion c'est
de dire c'est trop cher et donc ensuite
sans suivre des échanges par écrit donc
ils sont documentés que IgA a eu et que
vous aurez également vous avez peut-être
déjà d'ailleurs dans lesquels on discute
de ce projet des membres de mon cabinet
soutenant le projet et le détaillant et
le directeur de cabinet rappelant qu'il
y a une procédure qu'elle existe
rappelant par écrit les étapes de cette
procédure et invitant à ne pas débattre
de cette sorte mais à intégrer ce projet
dans le cadre du comité de sélection en
tout cas de la procédure qui existe
je sais pas si ça répond à d'autres
questions partiellement madame
partiellement à deux reprises vous savez
la question elle est quand même très
simple
quand il y a une position d'un cabinet
notamment écrite elle engage son
ministre on est bien d'accord bon il y a
une responsabilité conjointe voilà ce
qui me permet de vous dire d'ailleurs
tout de suite madame la ministre que
dans votre propos introductif il y a
quelques moments que ce soit jusqu'à
présent vous n'avez mis en cause votre
ou en jeu ou en discussion votre propre
responsabilité pour l'instant vous dites
c'est l'administration c'est le cabinet
voilà bon madame
quand le cabinet prend une position elle
est supposée être la position de la
ministre ou du ministre je veux dire de
manière faut pas de manière générale
c'est comme ça que les choses se font et
heureusement parce que sinon quel est
serait la qualité d'une intervention du
cabinet si ce n'était pas la voix de du
ministre voilà et donc et donc ça me
paraît très important de revenir dessus
alors
on a plusieurs plusieurs échanges on y
reviendra tout à l'heure sur plusieurs
plusieurs sociétés plusieurs
associations pardon mais
entre le 9 et le 13 avril par exemple
votre conseiller spécial interroge le
cpdr sur la bonne réception de la
demande de Monsieur sefaoui c'est à dire
que on va plus loin tout à l'heure on
rappellera mais vous connaissez cette
phrase du préfet Gravel qui
qui évidemment je vous la donne tout de
suite faut pas je la rappelle à tout le
monde mais c'est cifaoui indique je n'ai
pas pris cette alors sur Twitter je
prends encore une fois pas devant notre
voilà je le prends avec précaution je
n'ai pas pris cette initiative
spontanément j'y étais encouragé par des
représentants des pouvoirs publics
notamment par les membres du cabinet
madame Schiappa et par elle-même donc à
l'occasion sans doute de ce petit
contact furtif vous vous dites que il
vous arrive régulièrement d'encourager
bon
je suis donc quelque peu scandalisés en
constatant que les participes gentiment
au lynchage bon
ce sont ça c'est important ce sont les
membres du cabinet Marlène Schiappa qui
ont insisté pour que je prenne pas à la
riposte citoyenne
on peut imaginer les choses finalement
des gens qui sont sur ce terrain là
on est on l'a souvent dit dans ces
auditions sur comment dire un petit
nombre d'acteurs en tout état de cause
bon donc mais tout de même une chose et
comment dire d'avoir un contact une
autre est
d'encourager je reprends les termes
les membres du cabinet ont insisté pour
que je prenne pas à la riposte citoyenne
et puis on a des échanges derrière de
votre cabinet vers le secrétariat
général pour finalement avoir des
informations pour savoir si
la le dossier de candidature est bien
arrivé si on peut l'intégrer ça va très
loin c'est à dire que
le directeur de cabinet de Madame bac S
nous a fait une démonstration que je
trouve assez juste et assez classique
c'est à dire qu'un ministre un cabinet
est souvent comment dire reçoit souvent
des demandes et sollicités c'est évident
et
lorsqu'il est sollicité
il la tradition la méthode
l'organisation veut que le cabinet ou le
ministre transmettent à son
administration pour analyse le dossier
présenté voilà et ce garde-bien jusqu'à
comment dire à ce que le dossier soit
face l'objet d'un rapport par
l'administration se garde bien
d'intervenir dans le sujet là on est sur
quelque chose de très différent on est
sur quelque chose de très différent
parce que il y aurait eu donc une
sollicitation on vous demande de votre
avis vous pouvez pas nous répondre je
sais pas ce que le cabinet a fait s'il a
appelé monsieur Sifaoui s'il ne l'a pas
appelé si c'est Monsieur Sifaoui de
votre autorité est venue connaissant
mais c'est pas ce que ça nous dit ce que
nous disent les auditions ce que nous
disent les auditions c'est que d'une
alors l'hygia d'une part je viens de le
dire et les auditions monsieur Gravel
nous dit que il a reçu un coup de fil de
monsieur cifaoui lui indiquant que on
n'est pas du tout dans la transmission
par le cabinet à l'administration on est
sur quelque chose de totalement
différent de la ministre peut-être le
rapporteur
oui madame vous pouvez répondre à ce
point
madame la ministre
je crois avoir posé les questions je
vous prie mais je pensais que vous aviez
une aparté excusez-moi j'ai mal j'ai mal
interprété votre
regard
pardon monsieur le Président bien sûr je
vous réponds d'abord en ce qui concerne
ma responsabilité je me défonce pas je
me des repas je suis là devant vous et
j'entends endosser ma responsabilité
toute ma responsabilité pardon pour la
formulation mais aussi rien que ma
responsabilité que le ministre soit
comptable et soit
rendent des comptes et soir responsables
devant le Parlement de l'action menée
non seulement par lui-même mais aussi
par son cabinet bien évidemment et son
administration politiquement c'est c'est
bien évidemment normal et c'est pourquoi
bien évidemment je suis là autant que de
besoin maintenant et dans l'avenir si
vous avez besoin de complément
d'information ou autre donc j'ai
toujours en toute circonstances pris à
mes responsabilités j'ai énormément de
défauts certainement pas celui de me
dérober donc je suis là et bien sûr je
vous réponds dans toute ma
responsabilité et dans rien que ma
responsabilité moi je n'ai aucune et de
même que le mot coupable n'a pas été
prononcé par cette mission
le mot coupable nous on parle pas de
culpabilité on parle de responsabilité
bien sûr et personne n'est enfin à ma
connaissance moi je ne suis accusée de
rien donc bien évidemment c'est pas le
sujet je suis là pour vous aider à
établir des faits la matérialité des
faits au dehors des commentaires des uns
et des autres et la chronologie des
faits donc c'est bien là-dessus que
j'irai et d'ailleurs je je n'ai pas non
plus à
préjugé de culpabilité de quel capteur
que ce soit puisqu'il y a une
instruction judiciaire en cours qui les
concerne qui ne me concerne pas et donc
et donc ce concerne pas non plus bien
sûr bien évidemment donc tout ça pour
dire que cabinet a fait confiance à un
acteur qui à ce moment là un acteur
reconnu de ce sujet qui est monsieur
cifaoui qui est à ce moment là déjà
soutenu par le cipdr il y a des
rencontres qui sont documentées il y a
un site de monsieur cifaoui qui
s'appelle islamoscope qui est référencé
comme partenaire du cipdr et donc il y a
vraiment cette antériorité moi je veux
être très clair sur le fait puisque je
réponds pour ce que j'ai fait je n'ai
pas connaissance d'autres échanges
personnels mais Lydia et vous même et
peut-être la justice le diront mais moi
je suis formelle je vous le dis
sincèrement je n'ai à aucun moment
demandé ou passer commande à ce que
Monsieur Sifaoui soit priorisé ou mis au
dessus de la pile je n'avais aucune
raison de le faire et je ne l'ai pas
fait d'ailleurs le rapport de l'IGA est
très clair sur ma responsabilité dans le
cadre du processus de sélection
puisqu'il établit qu'après avoir
impuissé cette politique publique il dit
la ministre c'est effacer du processus
de sélection c'est la conclusion écrite
dans le rapport de l'igéa
de vous reprendre le rapport ne dit pas
ça
il y a juste avant la petite phrase qui
est selon les auditions menées
la ministre je pense n'a pas participé
cette tenue à l'écart mais il y a bien
avant la petite phrase selon les
personnes auditées
et puis d'autre part et puis d'autre
part l'inspection générale de
l'administration son rôle c'est de
contrôler l'administration elle est pas
là pour porter un jugement de
responsabilité politique en aucune façon
il ne l'a jamais fait je vous le dis et
je vous me demandez ma parole donc je
vous donne ma parole et sous serment je
vous dis que je n'ai à aucun moment ni
prioriser moi-même ni demander de
prioriser le dossier de Monsieur cifaoui
et j'ajoute que je n'avais aucune raison
de demander à prioriser le dossier de
Monsieur Sifaoui et que je ne l'ai pas
fait j'ajoute au demeurant que ce
dossier était soutenu par
l'administration par le cpdr puisque
manifestement il a été
donné un avis favorable au fait de
pouvoir financer ce dossier de manière
unanime par l'ensemble des membres du
comité de sélection c'est-à-dire tant
les membres du cabinet que les membres
de l'administration c'est en tout cas
les éléments dont moi je dispose
monsieur le Président en même temps
madame la ministre vous savez comment
les choses se passent c'est-à-dire que
lorsqu'on cabinet demande à
l'administration
de regarder de près un dossier se
réinterroge sur est-ce qu'il a bien été
déposé
participe à des à des discussions on y
viendra plus tard sur le montant à louer
bon l'administration a quand même du mal
quoi qu'on monsieur Gravel qui par
ailleurs a dit plutôt du bien de
Monsieur Sifaoui dans son audition qui
irait plutôt dans le sens d'un accord
mais quoi qu'il en soit lorsqu'une
demande Vienne au cabinet et donc de la
ministre de manière peut-être
involontaire c'est ce que vous nous
dites mais en fait quand le cabinet
parle à son administration on a toujours
la ministre ou le ministre derrière
quand on est dans l'administration et
donc on arrive à un accord cela ne nous
choque pas ce cas ce qui est important
et on y reviendra c'est la façon dont ça
dans sa c'est dans Ça c'est monté
c'est important
je vais rester sur la chronologie des
faits parce que j'ai toujours à ce stade
quelques difficultés à m'y retrouver
vous avez pas de matérialité de
chronologie moi je suis assez basique
de ce côté là parce que
le calendrier il est ce qu'il est donc
vous nous avez tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
évoqué un mail du 20 avril je vais juste
vous me permettre de vous corriger
puisque
ce qui a été
ce qui nous était transmis c'est un mail
du 6 avril 2001 et non pas du vin donc
adressé à votre cabinet qui
effectivement indiqué le montant de
300.000 euros qualifiés d'énormes
mais le 9 avril donc trois jours après
l'uspm envoie tout de même une demande
de subvention de 635
000 euros qui sera réduite à 300000
euros le 13 avril
2021 lors du comité de programmation je
rappelle qu'à ce stade le fond Marianne
n'est pas créé
à ce stade est-ce qu'on doit en déduire
que la décision d'octroyer les 300.000
euros à l'USSE ppm avait finalement été
non seulement envisagé mais je dirais
acté par vos équipes et par votre
cabinet en amont même du comité de
programmation dont je rappelle qu'il
s'est tenu le 13 avril et donc avant
même le dépôt officiel de la demande de
subvention
monsieur le rapporteur moi je tiens à
vous dire que mon point de vue sur ce
montant n'a changé à aucun moment vous
avez bien compris c'est pas la question
la question maintenant c'est la
procédure les montants et la séquence
dans laquelle
la subvention est déjà prêt accordée
bien sûr monsieur le regard qu'on porte
sur un montant qui procède à un
arbitrage ou à un non arbitrage
point de vue je l'ai donné à mon cabinet
par écrit et j'ai dit que pour moi
300.000 euros c'était une somme énorme
de surcroît si l'État était le seul
financeur c'est pourquoi à ma
connaissance
rétrospectivement aujourd'hui quand je
recoupe les éléments il aurait été
demandé à Monsieur Sifaoui de trouver
des co-financements d'après ce que j'ai
compris
j'entends je vous demande simplement de
confirmer je vous ai donné le séquençage
entre le 6 et le 13 avril des montants
est-ce qu'ils sont conformes ou est-ce
que je
commets une erreur est-ce que c'est la
manière de procéder et donc est-ce que
c'était finalement une subvention
fléchée avant même le fond Marianne je
ne peux pas vous dire Monsieur le
Rapporteur ce qui a procédé au
changement de montant dans la demande
je vais revenir
c'est une question importante parce que
tout simplement elle montre ou pas
mais en tout cas selon nous elle
démontre que le cabinet vous a
questionné sur un montant de subvention
à cette association l'US ppm avant même
que tout dossier soit déposé
aussi PDF donc il n'y a pas de dossier
déposé et votre cabinet vous interroge
sur un montant qui pourrait être affecté
à l'USPPM de 300.000 euros auquel vous
répondez c'est votre mail c'est énorme
ici mais la demande en réel elle arrive
après ce qui tend tout simplement à dire
que et bien il y a eu une décision
préalable de votre cabinet de soutenir
cette association avant même de recevoir
quelques dossiers que ce soit et que
cette doux d'ailleurs le la demande qui
est faite aussi PDR et alors est-ce que
vous avez reçu le dossier mais parce
qu'ils ont déjà une position préétablie
de dire oui pour 300.000 euros en accord
avec vous alors un accord avec vous
sous la réserve que vous dites c'est
énorme ici et il vous répondent que
répondre techniquement que c'est jouable
que s'il y a du que ça a du sens qui
était ce qui ne va pas et finalement ce
qui fait dire à l'IGA et c'est très
important que c'est des ni transparents
ni équitables c'est que des associations
ont finalement fait l'objet d'arbitrage
par votre cabinet
préalablement à toute demande et à tout
dépôt de dossier et ça c'est excusez moi
de vous le dire c'est votre mail même
que vous nous avez transmis pour comment
dire exprimer votre position sur les 300
000 qui dit ça qui dit que vous avez par
arbitré mais était questionné par votre
cabinet sur 300.000 euros avant même
tout dossier ce qui veut dire tout
simplement que effectivement dès le
départ cette procédure fait qu'il y a
plusieurs types d'associations et qui a
des associés en particulier qui sont
réglés avant en tout cas pour celle là
les faits sont établis
est-ce que vous contestez c'est fait
moi monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur je n'ai d'abord dans les
mails c'est à vérifier mais il me semble
beaucoup de précaution mais il me semble
que le mail de mon conseiller ne fait
pas référence je crois au fond Marianne
mais qui fait référence
ne mélangez pas je vous ai donné une
matérialité une séquence je vous demande
juste est-ce que vous contestez les
éléments que je vous ai présenté
que la question est la question est
claire soit des versements qui ont été
fléchés par avance vous le dites et
ça clarifie les choses moi monsieur le
rapporteur je n'ai moi je suis comme
vous matérialité chronologique et
matériellement je n'ai pas de fait qui
viennent dire que le cabinet donne un
ordre
de versement de cette subvention
d'abord le versement celui-ci PDR c'est
l'administration qui verse non il s'agit
c'est un pré fléchage sur un montant de
300000 qui d'ailleurs comme par hasard
devient finalement la proposition du
cpdr au moment du comité voilà c'est
tout simple je regarde monsieur le
Président ce que ce que ce dont je
dispose comme fait pour ces discussions
qui ont lieu il y a deux ans et donc je
me suis à ce dont je dispose ce dont je
dispose c'est qu'effectivement
manifestement les membres de mon cabinet
tout comme le cipdr était en soutien de
l'initiative portée par Monsieur cifaoui
leur mail démontre qu'ils ont un
enthousiasme vis-à-vis du projet de
Monsieur Sifaoui ça ne moi je n'ai pas
d'éléments qui vise à dire que le
cabinet aurait à ce moment là arbitrer
ou décider quelque chose avant le comité
de sélection et je tiens à rappeler par
quelle porte d'entrée arrive monsieur
Sifaoui c'est par le SV c'est avec
lequel il travaillait ou l'entretenait
des relations précédemment
et l'autre le cabinet et le cpdr
travailler avec enthousiasme c'était
finalement que vous validez la
enthousiasme dans un même j'interprète
enthousiasme je n'ai pas d'éléments
matériels
que vous n'avez pas contesté la mère
terrialité des séquences ce qui
finalement est pour moi un élément de
réponse c'est un élément de réponse qui
nous permettra madame la ministre
ensuite de rendre nos conclusions voilà
je ne fais pas de je ne tire pas
d'enseignement particulier j'avais
simplement besoin au titre de la
Commission de vérifier le déroulement et
la chronologie des faits et si vous me
permettez puisque il y a une réserve
savoir pour quelle raison au final il a
été décidé d'attribuer ces 300.000 euros
à l'USSE ppm
pourquoi ensuite d'ailleurs elle a
déposé une demande de d'un projet à
355000 euros dans le fond Marianne les
55000 euros supplémentaires
est-ce que c'est une
idée géniale et ce qui a eu un échange
avec le cipdr votre cabinet voire
vous-même au cours d'échanges dit furtif
voilà moi je j'ai simplement aussi
besoin de savoir quel est le rôle que
chacun a pu tenir ce qui n'a rien enfin
je veux aussi vous mettre parfaitement à
l'aise de répréhensible nous avons juste
besoin de comprendre et de faire la
lumière voilà au titre de la mission de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement et
de la dépense publique qui plus est avec
des associations et comme l'a dit à nos
collègues parfois dans nos collectivités
pour 1000 euros il faut montrer patte
blanche et avoir un dossier très carré
parfaitement à vos propos
je me permets simplement de dire que je
n'ai pas dans mes réponses ni confirmer
ni infirmer cette chronologie enfin
j'insiste parce que c'est quelque soit
le niveau d'importance de cette je ne
sais pas
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas en mesure
de vous je ne connais pas les échanges
qui ont pu avoir lieu sur ce sujet tout
ce que je sais est matériellement ce que
je sais c'est que le comité de sélection
est unanime sur le soutien qu'il faut
apporter à Monsieur CIFA oui je ne me
mêle pas du montant on m'indique que le
comité de sélection à part cette
remarque où je dis que en amont que je
trouve que c'était énorme le comité de
sélection propose un montant se met
d'accord sur un bénéficiaire qui est
l'association dans laquelle les monsieur
seifaoui et se met d'accord sur ce
montant et moi je ne BIF pas ce montant
ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre je ne
donne pas d'avis sur ce montant ici
le constat on y reviendra plus tard vous
ne l'invalidez pas
contrairement à la liste finale non non
dans la liste finale qu'on me présente
il y a des avec des montants et je ne je
n'ai pas de modification à apporter et
je veux dire que et pourquoi je ne le
sais pas c'est pas un désintérêt de ma
part je reviens à ce que je disais c'est
à dire que et on peut le déplorer on
peut on peut estimer que j'aurais dû le
faire mais en tout cas je me suis pas
mêlée d'une générique je suis pas
directeur d'administration ou préfet ou
chargé de mission et ne revient pas
l'attribution dossier par dossier de
chaque de chaque subvention on ne m'a
pas sollicité d'arbitrage infini
puisqu'il y avait un consensus et donc
ça a été ça a été engagé de la sorte sur
ce dossier là on va y revenir madame
madame la ministre envahir mais quand on
vous a juste dit la chronologie en
réalité la chronologie c'est vous qui
l'a donnez donc elle est pas fausse par
nature
vous l'avez donné vous nous avez
transmis un mail du 6 du 6 avril
c'est-à-dire antérieur au dépôt du
dossier qui est une autre date clarifiée
qui est le en avril et donc le 6 avril
votre cabinet arbitre sur un montant de
300000 euros qui comme par hasard
devient le montant qui est présenté en
comité en comité qui suit voilà ça c'est
la chronologie que vous avez donné donc
votre mail il est juste enfin je veux
dire la date est juste à partir de là
tout le reste est un briquet voilà
je vais je vais vous proposer une petite
pause avec les questions mais pas totale
les questions de nos collègues de la
commission donc dans l'ordre j'ai Roger
carochi puis Vincent et blé quelques
autres
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madame la ministre certains
ici ont une expérience ministérielle et
savent très bien qu'effectivement on ne
demande pas ces membres du cabinet de
faire rapport sur tout on ne vérifie pas
leurs agendas heureusement ni qui
reçoivent et heureusement on aurait des
problèmes en sens inverse
mais dans cette affaire
qui qui est aujourd'hui l'objet de la
commission d'enquête il y a un élément
un peu
non pas gênant mais un peu curieux vous
dites vous-même madame la ministre et je
veux bien vous croire que bon il y avait
un comité de sélection vous n'avez pas
intervenir sur le montant de des
ensembles vous n'avez pas d'ailleurs à
faire le choix c'est au comité de
sélection de le faire mais alors dans
ces conditions pourquoi votre cabinet
vous interpelle sur la somme qui serait
attribuée à Monsieur
avant le comité de sélection et vous
répondez vous-même c'est très bien de
l'avoir fait la somme me paraît énorme
ici parce que ça semble indiquer madame
la ministre qu'en réalité ce que
probable votre directeur de cabinet a
peut-être fait une présélection avant le
comité qu'on vous les a soumis quelques
idées ou en tout cas quelques montants
et que vous avez réagi au moins sur le
plus important celui de Monsieur sivaoui
d'ailleurs quand vous dites vous-même
monsieur cifaoui et son association
plutôt demander où avait un projet à 600
000 euros vous avez vous dites vous le
dites vous-même vous avez proposé à
l'association enfin vous votre cabinet
avait proposé à l'association de trouver
des financements complémentaires
ailleurs ce qui revient à dire que avant
même que le comité de sélection des
projets se réunissent décide
le projet de Monsieur cifaoui avait été
plus ou moins validé par votre cabinet
qu'on avait compris que ça coûterait
plus cher que 300.000 euros qu'on lui
avait proposé de trouver des
financesment privés parallèles et donc
on a un peu le sentiment que sans que
vous soyez forcément vous-même
totalement impliqué mais qu'en réalité
avant le comité de sélection
le cabinet avait pris le pas sur
l'administration pour décider
merci madame la ministre si vous voulez
bien vous prenez trois les quelques
questions qu'il y a on va s'en tenir
assis question d'inscrits les autres
viendront dans un deuxième temps donc
Vincent aybelais puis Victorin Lurel
rapidement bien sûr merci monsieur le
Président donc sénateur de la
Seine-et-Marne madame la ministre je
voudrais
vous interroger sur
le subventionnement d'une association
dont il n'a pas encore été beaucoup fait
état dans nos discussions d'aujourd'hui
qui est l'association reconstruire le
commun comme vous le savez sans doute
cette association a été constituée
seulement quelques semaines avant de
bénéficier des subventions d'État ce qui
est une chose qui personnellement m'a
beaucoup surpris car comme le rapporteur
général Husson
il faisait allusion tout à l'heure dans
les collectivités territoriales j'ai
présidé pour ma part une collectivité
importante quel conseil départemental de
Seine-et-Marne durant 11 années jamais
en 11 années nous n'avons subventionné
une association qui venait d'être
constituée tout simplement parce que
dans les conditions que nous émettons
pour subventionner une association
fusent de quelques centaines d'euros
alors a fortiori pour plus de 300000
nous demandons à disposer au moins des
comptes arrêtés d'un exercice entier
annuel de l'association et donc on ne
subventionne qu'à partir d'une année
complète d'existence c'est une
précaution je dirais qui me paraît
j'irai relativement normal donc je
voudrais vous demander si vous aviez
connaissance lorsque vous avez validé
l'ensemble des subventions accordées
dans le cadre de cet appel à projet si
vous aviez j'irai conscience que cette
association était de création récente ou
est-ce que vous l'ignoriez absolument et
est-ce que
[Musique]
qui semble-t-il n'existe pas est-ce
qu'il a fait l'objet de discussion avec
vos collaborateurs au sein du cabinet
avec les administrations en question ou
est-ce que et si c'est le cas est-ce que
il a été
sciemment
[Musique]
décidé que et bien ça n'était pas grave
de subventionner une association
débutante
et que j'irai
l'évolution assez rapide des questions
auxquelles le fond Marianne est destiné
à répondre j'irai pouvais justifier en
quelque sorte de retenir une jeune
association ou bien est-ce que tout ça
est en dehors de votre visibilité de
ministre je dirais en dehors des radars
merci merci Vincent madame la ministre
cette deuxième question vous la gardez
parce que le sujet qui est sur
reconstruire le commun va arriver
derrière et on l'a voilà et on
vous allez prendre des autres questions
alors la première vous pourrez répondre
la deuxième vous la gardez en mémoire
mais c'est quand on se rend sur le la
deuxième association un peu plus tard je
demande à chacun de bien vouloir
intervenir dans le champ de ce qui a été
déjà présenté parce que notre
audition va durer un petit peu et nous
avons d'autres thèmes victoriennes on
est bien sur la matière j'en suis pas
sûr monsieur le Président puisque
j'avais l'intention d'interroger la
ministre sur
l'US ppm qui est une association
union de société
d'éducation physique et de préparation
militaire
le DL l'Observatoire de la laïcité a été
dissous et vous avez donc créé le fond
Marianne pour développer pour lutter
contre le séparatisme et donc développer
un contre discours républicain
j'aimerais savoir
quel est votre vision de ce contre
discours républicain qu'est-ce qu'on
reprochait à la laïcité qui n'était pas
apparemment suffisante pour passer à une
préparation militaire et peut-être
paramilitaire
c'est bien ça le nom de l'association
c'est une vieille association endormie
qui s'est réveillée et qui reçoit des
subventions quel était votre vision de
ce
discours contre républicain
quels étaient les liens avec
certains essayistes quel était votre
inspiration
les qualités la teneur de ce discours là
avait vu des liens également avec le
printemps républicain
est-ce que vous pourriez m'expliquer ça
merci
Vincent Segouin
oui merci monsieur le Président
Madame le Ministre monsieur Gravel a
déclaré qu'il a appris que Lulu l'use
ppm pourrait bénéficier des fonds
Mariannes lors d'un appel téléphonique
de Mohamed sefaoui il me dit sortir d'un
rendez-vous avec la ministre et nous
sommes en mars 2021 qu'en est-il est-ce
que c'est vrai
merci
Daniel broyier
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre la question que je voudrais
vous poser c'est pour mettre en place ce
contre discours républicain avez-vous
demandé à votre cabinet à
l'administration de chercher des acteurs
ou de chercher des associations dans
l'action était déjà visibles et réputée
parce qu'il y a pour moi une
interrogation vous dites je n'avais
aucune raison d'appuyer monsieur cifaoui
aviez-vous des raisons inverses de ne
pas l'appuyer et comment se fait-il que
l'administration semble dialoguer avec
un acteur avant de dialoguer avec une
association c'est pour moi une
interrogation il me semblait que on
allait chercher dans le les associations
déjà engagées dans cette action plutôt
que de cibler des acteurs donc vous
liez-vous qu'il y ait des acteurs vous
vouliez vous qu'on aille chercher
l'ensemble des associations qui
intervenaient dans le champ de la
défense des valeurs de la République
merci Daniel Christian Billac
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
il y a quelques années j'étais à
l'association des vers de France et nous
avions créé un groupe de travail qui
avait produit bekoum sur la laïcité et à
cette occasion nous l'avons auditionné
beaucoup de ces acteurs de terrain que
vous avez cité et qui font un travail
remarquable la défaite de laïcité et de
la valeur de la République il s'agit
pour beaucoup d'entre eux de coach
sportifs qui travaillent auprès des
jeunes des clubs sportifs
essentiellement de football ou de boxe
qui font le travail remarquable et moi
la question que je vous pose quelle
dotation ont obtenu chez clubs qui sont
déjà impliqués qui travaillent déjà dans
les quartiers quand une existence
reconnue ça rejoint un peu la question
de mon collègue voyez et je n'ai pas
souvenance par contre d'avoir des
journées le FPPM
comme acteur de terrain et comment
expliquer ces 300000 euros pour conclure
très rapidement je voudrais quand même
dire que moi je crois que ce fond malade
était une très bonne idée au départ
c'était une très bonne idée parce que
nous avons besoin de défendre la
République et ses valeurs et que je
n'aurais je ne ferais pas content je
suis à la fin de cette procédure ont
jeté je peux me permettre d'expression
peu populaire le bébé avait l'eau du
bain et que si on fasse plaisir au
salafiste de tout poil et à ceux qui les
soutiennent
merci pour non pas cette question mais
ce commentaire Gérard Longuet
oui monsieur le Président c'est
exactement la même observation que mon
prédécesseur madame la ministre vous
avez été en charge d'une responsabilité
extraordinairement lourde et nouvelle
c'est de bâtir un Dédé à bâtir un
discours pour défendre la laïcité
républicaine vis-à-vis de population qui
ont à l'égard de la religion n'ont pas
le même historique que la plupart de nos
compatriotes avez-vous rédiger un
document de base une charte de base de
en fait une la volonté politique et la
définition de votre projet politique
vous êtes complètement dans votre
responsabilité
des en charge d'un sujet majeur votre
équipe va le mettre en oeuvre va
mobiliser un fond qui est préexistant
mais qui a un objectif très différent la
lutte contre la délinquance tu as tout à
fait raison le délinquance de les
quartiers l'Association Sportive foot
c'est très bien mais là on parle de
quelque chose de très différent c'est un
message avec un corps de doctrine et ce
qu'on reprochait justement
l'Observatoire de la laïcité c'est de ne
pas avoir de cordes doctrine de ne pas
avoir de limites et de ne pas avoir de
règles de comportement donc avez-vous
bâti avez-vous l'occasion à vous le
temps tout simplement et la possibilité
de bâtir ce corps de doctrine avant de
de recruter des porte-parole
nous poursuivrons les questions après la
deuxième séquence si vous le voulez bien
pour avancer et aussi pour permettre la
ministre faire la synthèse des six
premières questions qu'elle avait bien
répondre
bien sûr monsieur le Président je vous
remercie
d'abord
alors d'abord je me permets de revenir
juste très brièvement sur votre dernier
propos conclusif disant que dans la
chronologie le cabinet avait arbitré par
mail les montants etc et pardon risque
de me répéter mais je n'ai pas dans les
échanges de mails d'arbitrage du cabinet
je tiens à le dire pour pas qu'il soit
retenu que j'aurais implicitement validé
cela dans les échanges de mails il y a
des discussions on peut voir les
positions et les points de vue des uns
et les autres mais il n'y a pas
d'arbitrage écrit en tout cas
matériellement je me permets de le dire
monsieur le ministre karucci pour
répondre à votre à vos différentes
questions vous faites référence aux
échanges de mails notamment que j'ai eu
avec mon cabinet en observant qu'ils
sont antérieurs au fond Marianne c'est
tout à fait juste et c'est d'ailleurs
pour cette raison que dans ces échanges
de mails ne figure pas de mention au
fond Marianne à ce moment là je ne dis
pas que ça ne veut pas dire que les
échanges ne soient pas intéressant au
regard de l'enquête qui est en train de
d'être mener ou de l'instruction qui est
en train d'être menée mais en tout cas
on n'est pas en train d'arbitrer des
subventions du fond Marianne du tout on
est en train justement d'avoir ce
compte-rendu thématique d'un membre de
mon cabinet sur un rendez-vous c'est
moi-même qui a souhaité porter ce mail à
la connaissance de la commission
d'enquête et le donner spontanément
d'initiatives parce que j'ai trouvé
justement qu'il éclairait ses débats et
d'ailleurs dans ces messages on voit que
les membres du cabinet se répondent et
me répondent le directeur de cabinet met
fin à l'échange par la nature de sa
réponse puisque le directeur de cabinet
rappelle que pour toute attribuer son
subventions il y a une procédure et que
donc l'échange s'arrête là et reporter à
l'échange au moment des procédures
afférentes et il propose d'ailleurs à ce
moment-là un process pour ce qui est pas
encore le fond Marianne mais ce qui est
l'activité de entre guillemets contre
discours républicain il rappelle c'est
un long mail mais je pense que chacun là
dans le il rappelle le process qu'il
propose avec une validation
ministérielle infinie mais avec une
sélection une instruction des dossiers
par l'administration donc c'est
véritablement cette procédure qui vient
détailler dans ce mail là ça me semble
important et ça me semble important
aussi parce qu'on parlait des la chaîne
de hiérarchie finalement et des
responsabilités de chacun et le
directeur de cabinet a préféré est
parfaitement dans son rôle en disant il
y a une procédure donc on en discute pas
comme ça par message c'est le
sous-entendu il écrit pas comme ça mais
c'est le sous-entendu de son mail quand
il renvoie au comité de sélection
monsieur le sénateur LB sur la question
de la date de création de reconstruire
le commun c'est vrai que l'objet du faux
on la garde pour la suite quand on
parlera
voilà rembobiner je n'ai pas répondu à
monsieur le sénateur LV là dessus tout à
l'heure bien sûr absolument monsieur le
sénateur l'URL vous avez parlé de
discours contre républicain il y a pas
de discours contre républicain je sais
pas si c'est oui d'accord ce que vous
avez dit le discours contre républicain
c'est un lapsus donc je tiens à être
clair sur ce sujet et j'admets parce que
j'ai entendu certains débats que cette
appellation n'est peut-être pas la plus
limpide qui soit avec d'ailleurs on peut
politiquement mais c'est un autre sujet
ça interroger sur le non qu'on donne à
ce discours puisque nous qu'est-ce que
nous mettons dedans et nous mettons
dedans le fait de répondre à tout
discours dit séparatiste qui peut
exister et donc de répondre
essentiellement à ce qu'on appelle le
terreau du terrorisme et donc au
discours de radicalisation et
d'islamisme mais plus largement au
discours qui peuvent attenter aux
institutions à la République et l'idée
c'est justement d'aider les jeunes
notamment qui sont sur ces réseaux
sociaux à se faire un propre avis à
exercer leur libre arbitre et à entendre
différentes positions sur ce sujet je
souhaiterais répondre à votre question
sur le printemps républicain et je vous
remercie de la poser parce que ça va me
permettre de clarifier un certain nombre
de choses d'abord
je n'ai rien contre le printemps
républicain mais je ne suis pas membre
du printemps républicain je tiens à le
dire ici parce que dans les
sous-entendus qui ont été non pas dans
cette commission d'enquête bien sûr mais
dans les commentaires qui en ont été
faits on entend un peu tout et n'importe
quoi et on attribue des amis à tort et
on attribue des appartenances à tort pas
plus que je ne suis pas ami avec
Monsieur Sifaoui je n'ai rien contre lui
mais pas de relation personnelle je n'ai
rien contre le printemps républicain
mais je ne suis pas membre du printemps
républicain vous avez des images des
reportages des photos d'événements de
lancement de printemps républicain jeune
n'y figure pas et pourquoi je n'y suis
pas je n'en suis pas membre je pourrais
honnêtement c'est pas interdit mais il
s'avère que je ne le suis pas et il
s'avère également que le printemps
républicain n'a pas été associée à la
constitution du fond Marianne à aucun
moment en tout cas pas à ma connaissance
et pas par moi à aucun moment je ne vais
voir le printemps républicain dans le
cadre du fond Marianne et d'ailleurs
eux-mêmes ont souhaité faire un
communiqué pour dire qu'il n'avait pas
été associé d'aucune manière
je vais vous demander malheureusement
c'est l'exercice nous avons énormément
de questions à vous poser vous avez
intérêt d'ailleurs vous-même à répondre
à toutes ces questions républicain voilà
c'est ma réponse
monsieur le sénateur se goin
[Musique]
oui je n'ai pas par du mal à me relire
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas annoncé à
Monsieur Sifaoui en rendez-vous qu'il
aurait une subvention je l'ai je dis
tout à l'heure que c'était faux je pense
je pense que Monsieur préfet Gravel a dû
mal comprendre ou qu'il y a une
incompréhension dans la manière dont les
choses se sont dites entre monsieur
Sifaoui et Monsieur le Préfet Gravel
mais je suis formelle il n'est pas
possible et les éléments matériels le
démontrent agenda message etc je n'ai
pas reçu Monsieur cifaoui dans mon
bureau en mars pour lui annoncer une
subvention donc je dément cela et
l'effet démontre que ce n'est pas
possible
monsieur le sénateur Brière
[Musique]
je vais me répéter mais du coup je vais
me répéter extraordinairement rapidement
mais je n'avais pas de raison de
soutenir monsieur cifaoui son projet je
n'avais pas non plus de raison de m'y
opposer à ce moment-là lui égard à ce
que l'on connaissait de cela et je me
permets de répéter puisque je vous ai
entendu Escal qualité demande de la
commission d'enquête dire sur public
c'est là que j'étais ami de Monsieur
Sifaoui et que c'était donc la
République des copains je répète je ne
suis pas copine de Monsieur cifaoui et
que et que je ne suis pas copine de
Monsieur Sifaoui monsieur le sénateur
bilac sur les clubs sportifs français
vous avez
absolument raison sur le rôle absolument
fondamental joué par les clubs sportifs
et c'est pour ça que certaines activités
sportives d'ailleurs sont financées par
le FIPD au titre de la prévention de la
radicalisation de la délinquance etc et
je suis je tiens à souligner que le fond
Marianne à vocation à soutenir du
discours en ligne sur les réseaux
sociaux et on y reviendra parce que
c'est important pour un des autres
sujets que nous allons aborder je pense
tout à l'heure mais le but du fond
Marianne n'est pas de financer des
activités sportives ces activités elles
sont déjà financées par ailleurs sur
d'autres lignes budgétaires donc ce
n'est pas son objet et j'ai souri quand
vous avez dit il faut pas jeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain parce que c'est ce
que je répète depuis des semaines et
qu'effectivement je crois aussi que
cette politique publique de lutte contre
le cyber islamisme les fondamentale qui
ne faut pas la cesser et qu'il ne faut
pas effectivement jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain je vous rejoins
parfaitement et pour conclure pour cette
première salle je me le seul sénateur
est longue la question de la doctrine
elle est fondamentale je vous rejoins
complètement et d'ailleurs nous avons
nous avions initié un travail de
doctrine confié au sgcpdr pour dire
pardon
tous les acronymes de la région le
secrétariat général du Comité
intermittal de prévention de la
délinquance et de la radicalisation
pardon pour l'acronyme nous avons nous
avions confié le travail sur cette sur
cette doctrine et il y a deux sujets que
je souhaite ici distinguer qui sont les
sujets là ici et les sujets font
Marianne le sujet font mariage le fond
Marianne il est pas là pour alimenter
des débats de ligne autour des questions
de laïcité il est vraiment là pour
porter un discours républicain et
définir ce qui nous rassemblent face à
des discours notamment de radicalisation
donc il y a une doctrine sur le cyber
islamiste qui est réalisé par les
services du ministère de l'Intérieur en
charge de cela et une doctrine fond
Marianne qui donne lieu à l'appel à
projet réalisé par l'USVC et PDR
j'imagine que les travaux sont à mon
avis dans les archives qui sont à
disposition j'espère avoir répondu à
l'ensemble des questions
pas du tout trouvé venait de parler
d'appel à projet je vais revenir 16
avril 2021 un mail du directeur de
cabinet de votre directeur de cabinet au
secrétaire général du cpdr indique que
la durée de l'appel à projet doit être
raccourci et avancé finalement ça
devrait se tenir en trois semaines
initialement le préfet nous a dit elle
habite juste les trois mois et il doit
avoir lieu le mail et du 16 avril en 3
semaines entre le 20 avril donc 4 jours
après et le 10 mai alors qu'il était
initialement prévu qu'il se déroule
entre le 1er mai et le 30 juin ce qui
était déjà plus court que le delà
habituel et est-ce que
l'appel à projet a donc été
lancé quatre jours après
ce mail avez-vous été de près ou de loin
partie prenante de cette décision quelle
raison explique cette
accélération du calendrier et ce que
vous pensez à ce stade aujourd'hui avec
une un certain recul que finalement
c'était un bon délai suffisant et
permettant de bien conduire cet appel à
projet soit original que vous êtes dont
vous avez explicité l'orientation
oui monsieur le rapporteur sur la
question du calendrier dans le cadre de
l'appel à projet je ne me suis pas
personnellement mêlée de la mise en
oeuvre et de l'ingénierie des
dispositifs ce que je sais en revanche
c'est que il n'y a aucune alerte qui me
remonte de la part de l'administration
quant à cédé j'ai regardé et je n'ai pas
une note ou une alerte
écrite ou matérielle de l'administration
disant que ce délai n'est pas tenable et
que donc il préconise un autre délai
parce qu'ils ne seront pas faire dans ce
délai le délai trois semaines pour
recueillir les candidatures c'est vrai
qu'il peut paraître contraint il est
serré ce délai mais il nous apparaissait
adapter au regard de la mobilisation qui
était organisée depuis des mois puisque
je rappelle et ces documenter que ça
fait plusieurs mois à ce moment là que
j'ai impulsé cette cette demande de
création du fond Marianne il y a des
réflexions qui étaient en cours on en a
parlé depuis l'automne et le SVC PDR
pouvez aussi s'appuyer sur justement
l'ensemble de ces de ces travaux de ces
entretiens menés avec les experts depuis
l'automne j'ajoute qu'on a mobilisé et
ce dans un contexte de diminution des
effectifs en administration centrale au
ministère de l'intérieur on a réussi à
mobiliser pour le sgpdr 17 recrutement
supplémentaires au 20 avril ça donne à
penser qu'il y a des moyens humains
suffisants dans l'administration à ce
moment-là pour tenir les délais et
j'ajoute pour conclure que les délais
courts ils n'ont pas semblé posé de
difficultés particulières dans la mesure
où il y a eu 71 dossiers qui ont été
présentés dans ce délai pour candidater
à cet appel à projet ça ne va pas
empêché de candidater si vous voulez mon
avis mais ça n'est qu'un avis 71 pour un
appel à projet national c'est-à-dire
moins d'un par département sachant que
vous avez déjà des opérateurs on peut
considérer que si vous considérez que
c'est une réussite on peut considérer
qu'elle est au moins en demi teinte
à la fois de donner des éléments
d'éclaircissement donc en fait ce qui
continue de m'étonner je vous le dis
vous n'êtes jamais à l'origine de la
décision vous la prenez c'est votre
administration le cabinet ne vous alerte
pas vous dites j'ai pas de note ça
s'accélère oui il faut aller vite 4
jours après on décide
20 jours après la décision
est prise finalement ça ne nuit pas
c'est ce que j'en conclus c'est délai
très resserrés à la qualité de la
sélection aux procédures à respecter
pour avoir à la fois une transparence
des grilles d'analyse pour ensuite
pouvoir en toute connaissance de cause
avec un jury le plus averti possible
procéder à une sélection sachant
néanmoins le président rénal l'a rappelé
on voit bien qu'il y a quand même dans
les acteurs qui travaillaient jusqu'à
maintenant
en bon intelligence avec le gouvernement
est dans le cadre du FIPD que certains
vont forcément être intéressés candidaté
c'est leur liberté voilà il y aura plus
ou moins de fléchages donc finalement
tout ça n'a pas mis cette accélération
ça peut-être même permis d'avoir une
meilleure qualité de réponse c'est
d'être plus performant avec une
méthodologie bien cadrée c'est ce que
vous pensez aujourd'hui
cela apporteur moi je n'ai que mon
humble avis mais
bien sûr
plus dans la même responsabilité ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir des humbles agis
que je partage avec vous aujourd'hui sur
le nombre de dossiers reçus
c'est mon troisième ministère ça fait
c'est ma septième année que j'exerce des
responsabilités ministérielles j'étais
adjointe au maire précédemment j'ai
aussi participer à de nombreux appels à
projets où j'en ai impulsé et 71
réponses pour un sujet par des mémoire
expression mais de niche c'est important
il ne s'agit pas là d'un appel à projet
auquel le tout venant peut répondre il
s'agit d'un appel à projet qui s'adresse
à des experts de la lutte contre la
radicalisation
spécifiquement sur les réseaux sociaux
ou en ligne donc on est 71 personnes
structures qui soient touchées et qui
répondent moi je trouve que c'est un
nombre important je ne vous dis pas que
tout a été bien fait parce qu'il est
documenté aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas
le cas bien sûr les choses auraient pu
être faites différemment mieux fait et
je disais tout à l'heure vos retours
d'expérience nous dirons en quel sens
dans l'avenir nous pourrons mieux
ficeler cela mais à ce moment là bien
sûr c'est le cas je veux dire également
que ce que la façon monsieur rapporteur
dont vous présentez les choses laisse à
penser que que je subirai les fesses
sauf votre espèce sur l'interprétation
de ce que vous dites je rappelle encore
le rôle de chacun
le ministre suit bien sûr les commandes
politiques et les dossiers qu'il a
impulsé auprès de l'administration mais
n'est pas là encore dans la mise en
oeuvre au jour le jour ou dans
l'indénérique ce que veut savoir le
ministre c'est si ça avance si les
sujets débouche sont pris en main sont
traités si on est sur le ballon et pas
nécessairement quelle est la date de
rendu de la première étape des porteurs
de projets c'est en tout cas ma manière
de faire elle est peut-être pas bonne
mais en tout cas c'est la manière dont
je suis les choses à ce moment là madame
simplement quand on dit on a 71 réponse
ça montre que le temps était suffisant
quand on regarde donc et votre directeur
de cabinet d'ailleurs avait regardé un
petit peu un éclairage donc il y a 54
sur 71 qui sont pas retenus donc on
verra que sur certains il y a des
questions à vous poser mais pour
l'essentiel ce sont des projets qui sont
tout simplement hors sujets des rapports
qui sont hors sujet c'est à dire c'est
un sujet sur la mise en ligne les
réseaux sociaux comment on fait du
contre discours sur les réseaux sociaux
et on vous répond à ces
traditionnellement sur des actions du
FPD donc vous avez déjà 54 qui passe à
la trappe au moins une cinquantaine on
va dire d'autres républus peut-être être
retenues mais 54 et sur les 17 il y en a
que 5
finalement en dehors des des deux gros
dont on parle pour l'essentiel il y en a
que cinq autres si vous voulez qui sont
nouveaux donc le reste c'est des
associations qu'on a l'habitude de
travailler avec les cypridaire qui ont
le temps de répondre à ça et de modifier
et aussi parce qu'ils ont en contact du
cpda permanent et donc ils ajustent leur
propositions ils ont un petit peu plus
pour faire des actions dans ce domaine
donc vous voyez que au résultat de cet
appel d'offre et la la raison c'est sans
doute que ce domaine pas facile mais
aussi la raison c'est que le délai est
tellement court que ni répondre que ceux
qui sont déjà connus du site PDR et puis
quelques toutes petites associations qui
proposent des tout petits projets et que
finalement il y a deux gros projets qui
arrivent sur le bureau et ces deux
projets n'arrivent pas de manière de la
manière
identique aux autres c'est à dire que
l'un vient on y revient pas mais on le
réaffirme par votre cabinet et l'autre
vient plutôt par le cipdr lui-même qui a
eu ce contact avec une association et
qui souhaite la pousser ou l'aider voilà
donc il faut bien voir que tout ça
que vous pouvez pas dire il y a eu 71
réponses et donc c'est très bon non il y
a eu beaucoup de réponses hors jeu
l'essentiel
raison pour laquelle je disais plutôt un
bilan en demi-tente madame la ministre
alors je veux vous mettre
parfaitement et à l'aise et sereine je
crois pas avoir jusqu'à maintenant
fais passer le message comme quoi je
penserai ou pourrait croire que vous
subissiez l'effet je pense au contraire
votre parcours vous venez de le rappeler
une expérience ministérielle
démontre plutôt que vous avez une
capacité à faire face à beaucoup de
responsabilités et je dirais même à
toutes les situations vous êtes voilà
aujourd'hui
dans un temps où vous répondez à un
questionnement je le redis vous l'avez
dit à de multiples reprises d'ailleurs
sous serment nous on essaie on a à cœur
de vouloir faire la lumière comprendre
et on va s'en tenir si vous voulez bien
à ça
est-ce que vous aviez toujours sur appel
à projet déjà rencontré
certains des lauréats avant même le la
création du fond Marianne est-ce que
vous aviez eu des échanges ah oui avec
certains vous l'avez dit Monsieur
Sifaoui et avec reconstruire le commun
à ma connaissance monsieur rapporteur je
n'ai pas reçu les responsables de
l'association reconstruire le commun on
pourrait tout à fait honnête avec vous
j'ai pas en tête la totalité des noms ou
des visages des gens qui ont pris part à
ce projet puisque j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il y avait des porteurs de projets et
des prestataires ou des bénévoles au
sein du projet qui était intervenu ce
que je peux dire c'est que j'ai pas de
relation antérieure ou personnelle avec
elle ou eux mais je peux vous certifier
de les avoir jamais croisé dans quelques
endroits que ce soit ou même ni même je
ne sais pas si je les ai reçus sous
d'autres casquettes en tout cas j'ai pas
de souvenir de les avoir reçus mais ça
veut pas dire que ce soit impossible
reconstruire le commun fait partie le
président Arnal vient de l'évoquer de
des associations qui ont reçu de fortes
dotations c'est une association qui
était de création récente puisque elle
avait été créée en toute fin d'année
2020 et que même le versement le
préversement de 39000 euros j'appellerai
le l'appui à la création
avait été versée comment dirais-je au
tout début de l'année 2021 on a parlé de
l'uspm sur le manque d'expérience
finalement des sommes importantes dans
les deux cas sur des associations
US EPM avec un petit budget convenance
en 50000 euros une reconstruire le
commun une association toute nouvelle
portée sur les fonds bâtissements avec
le soutien de l'État 39000 euros à qui
vous avez attribué donc des
montants importants des subventions Sana
provoqué
pas d'alerte ça n'a pas provoqué
d'alerte particulière au sein de votre
équipe on va parvenir sur les
normissimes mais puisque comme ils
obtiendront quand même et même davantage
que les 300 000 et reconstruire le
commun il y a il y a des il y a des
trous dans les mailles
est-ce que vous pouvez du coup rajouter
la question de Monsieur Hublet à ce
stade
dans le même dans le même domaine oui
bien sûr alors peut-être commencer
monsieur le sénateur par vous répondre
le projet du fond Marianne c'est aussi
et c'est pourquoi nous vous ont aussi
cet appel à projet au-delà de la volonté
d'être transparent à ce moment-là c'est
de faire émerger aussi de nouveaux
acteurs et justement de tâcher de ne pas
travailler qu'avec celles et ceux qui
sont connus du cpdr le but c'est de
toucher la jeunesse sur les réseaux
sociaux et donc de pouvoir aussi
soutenir des acteurs émergents parce
qu'il y a un caractère un peu innovant
ou expérimental à se contredours je mets
des guillemets des précautions
républicain
et donc moi j'ai pas souvenir d'avoir
été informé ou alerté sur les 39 ke que
demande reconstruire le commun
il y a un montant de subvention qui je
comprends est lié aux besoins de
recrutement ou de formation aux médias
en tout cas c'est ce que je recoupe
aujourd'hui dans les dans les documents
mais je ne prends pas part et je n'ai
pas d'alerte sur le montant de la
subvention pour reconstruire le commun
je sais pas si vous avez d'autres
questions précisions par rapport à cela
non je voudrais simplement dire puisque
vous avez évoqué les moyens dont vous
disposiez les renforts en personnels
juste pour que nos collègues c'est les
ceux qui suivent cette audition soit
parfaitement informée à ma connaissance
l'instruction des dossiers étaient sous
la responsabilité d'une seule personne
raison pour laquelle je continue de
m'interroger sur la solidité de la
méthode sa transparence c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs ce qui a amené je le rappelle
l'igéa a considéré que l'appel à projet
n'avait été ni transparent ni équitable
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur simplement porter à votre
connaissance le fait que moi j'ai appris
que les dossiers du fond Marianne
étaient gérés par une personne une seule
personne et qui je crois exercent comme
chargé de mission au cpdr je l'ai appris
au cours du rapport de l'hygia et des
auditions qui ont été menées dans cette
commission d'enquête nous nous avions
obtenu les arbitrages politiques
nécessaires avec mon cabinet pour
renforcer en moyenne humain
considérablement le cipdr et donc
notamment cette action de contre
discours républicain merci madame le
ministre mais je rappelle aussi que
après les événements très graves qui est
sont à l'origine de la création du fond
Marianne le gouvernement avait mis une
communication puissante notamment par
vous-même pour expliquer qu'il allait
agir et monter au combat donc je
simplement je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire de manière placide que vous
découvrez après je pense qu'un ou une
ministre lorsqu'il est en action qui
décide d'un plan d'action et de combat
pour lutter contre les séparatismes
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux il
s'assure de la mise en oeuvre parce que
quand vous faites une annonce sur une
telle politique il y avait une telle
ambition il s'agit pas après que ça se
dégonfle un peu comme un ballon de
baudruche je pense que c'est en tous les
cas ça n'a jamais été j'imagine dans la
tête de personne voilà c'est tout c'est
il y a une distorsion assez importante
entre les moyens
consacrés à l'examen des candidatures
sur un temps très court resserré avec
une mise en action hyper rapide c'est le
constat je dirais factuel que je dresse
à cet instant
bien sûr merci Monsieur rapporteur je me
bien sûr c'est votre appréciation elle
est parfaitement légitime je me permets
de rappeler que
alors je ne la trouve pas exactement ce
rapporteur avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour vous-même personnellement et pour
la commission plus généralement et enfin
c'est mon avis c'est pourquoi je me
permets de vous répondre le fond
Marianne
c'est une petite partie des politiques
publiques qui sont menées par le
gouvernement en général et par votre
serviteur en particulier sur la question
de la lutte contre le terreau du
terrorisme j'ai évoqué très rapidement
quelques exemples dans mon propos
liminaire et je ne vais pas par respect
pour le temps qui nous est en partie
déroulé la totalité de la politique
publique mais vous savez que par exemple
l'action de renfort de Pharo c'est
absolument fondamental Faro ce n'est pas
ouvert 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7
à ce moment-là nous obtenons des
arbitrages nécessaires au plus haut
niveau pour faire ouvrir farros 24
heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 pour que
des pouvoirs importants nous mobilisons
les plateformes les réseaux sociaux nous
réactivons une initiative qui avait été
lancée par Monsieur Miss Bernard
Cazeneuve à l'époque pour avoir une
instance de dialogue avec les
plateformes et les réseaux sociaux pour
pouvoir communiquer notamment des
informations à l'enquête quand il y a
des contenus d'incitation au terroristes
qui sont portées il y a toute une action
législative qui va avec je n'apprends
pas au parlementaire parce que vous
savez vous avez pris par assez débats
notamment sur la clause portée par
Monsieur le Ministre de la Justice et
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur sur
le fait qu'il est désormais pénalement
répréhensible de communiquer des
éléments des informations personnelles
contre une personne en ligne égard à une
menace islamiste sous-jacente j'arrête
là ma liste mais en fait la
communication portée et que je porte
c'est juste avec force et que je
tâcherai de continuer à porter avec
force elle ne porte pas que sur le fond
Marianne c'est une accroche avec une
autre politique publique
portant sur le fond Marianne je vais
vous faire une dernière réponse la
personne que j'évoquais la personne
ressource était également membre du
comité de sélection je rappelle que dans
ce com ité de sélection il y avait
également trois membres de votre cabinet
donc là j'ai une vraie difficulté avec
trois membres de votre cabinet vous ne
pouviez pas ignoriez
ignorer pardon la difficulté pour une
seule personne à inscrire les dossiers
et vous le saviez en temps réel
monsieur le rapporteur avec je ne savais
pas d'ailleurs le rapport hygial le
documente et je vous inviterai à le dire
la charge émission qui est que vous avez
je crois auditionner qui avait demandé
d'après ce que dit le rapport je n'ai
pas connaissance je rapporte maintenant
c'est ce propos-là semble avoir demandé
un renfort renfort qui avait été refusé
par sa hiérarchie au niveau
administratif et donc l'hygia c'est pour
cela qu'elle qualifie cela de manque de
discernement de la part de la personne
qui a refusé les moyens mais à aucun
moment ça ne remonte jusqu'à moi et je
ne crois pas jusqu'à mon cabinet le fait
qu'il y ait un manque de moyens
ce que vous dites vous êtes en train de
nous dire qu'avec trois membres de votre
cabinet vous n'êtes au courant de rien
sur comment dirais-je une séquence de
trois semaines d'un fond Marianne dont
vous déclarez l'urgence à agir voilà
monsieur le rapporteur non mais je tire
simplement un enseignement de la réalité
de fait et d'actes qui sont reportés et
rapportés par des voies diverses au
cours des auditions ces touches propose
qu'on poursuive si vous si vous me le
permettez
je voudrais que
très change avec le directeur
d'administration et encore aujourd'hui
dans des dossiers dont j'ai la
responsabilité je ne demande pas au
directeur de l'administration quel est
le nom des personnes qui sont en train
d'instruire tel ou tel dossier au sein
de l'administration ça n'est pas le rôle
du Miss je termine nous partageons votre
réponse mais c'est pas la question
voilà si on répond pas à la question la
question c'est de dire dans le comité de
sélection il y avait trois membres de
votre cabinet qui était informé ne
fichent que par la chargée de mission en
question qu'il a dit clairement devant
truc il y avait une difficulté à gérer
le nombre de dossiers etc voilà ça
aurait pu remonter c'est toujours cette
fameuse relation cabinet
ministre qui est un peu toujours un trou
noir malgré tout
voilà c'est là dessus que ça repose mais
on entend votre réponse
alors quelques réponses
questions qui vont appeler les
rencontres très rapides et puis on
reviendra sur des sujets un peu plus
d'abord il nous avait été dit que vous
deviez initialement participer au comité
de sélection du 21 mai c'est-à-dire du
fond Marianne alors peut-être pour
l'ouvrir peut-être pour être présente
tout le temps en tout cas ça ne se fait
pas quels sont les raisons
très sincèrement monsieur le prison j'en
ai pas souvenir ça me paraît orthogonale
que le ministre soit lui-même dans le
comité de sélection je n'ai pas souvenir
qu'il m'est que ce que ça met été
proposé je ne sais je ne peux pas vous
répondre j'en ai pas de souvenir j'ai
pas d'éléments qui viennent
à l'époque c'est dans les documents qui
nous ont été envoyés notamment par le
cpdr donc il était précisé que vous
ouvriez un minima vous ouvriers ma
prononcez pas mais vous étiez là au
comité de sélection et derrière il était
prévu d'ailleurs un point presse ce qui
ne paraît pas logique puisque c'était un
peu la traduction le côté sélection
c'était la traduction de de finalement
la politique vous aviez initié donc
voilà vous avez pas ce souvenir d'un
point presque a été annulé à ce moment
là etc pas du tout voilà donc donc
[Applaudissements]
alors le lien bien sûr nous intéresse
toujours
dans l'échelle de connaissances du
dossier vous l'avez dit le fond Marianne
c'est un élément parmi bien d'autres
plus important en tout cas
farose voilà donc des sujets très
importants de ce plan général voulu par
le Président de la République et le
gouvernement ensuite
et qui ne fait pas de qui n'appelle pas
de commentaires particuliers tant nous
sommes dans une période particulière bon
est-ce que vous avez d'une façon ou
d'une autre est-ce que ça a été l'objet
de discussion avec votre Ministre
tutelle monsieur Gérald Darmanin et si
oui sur quoi ça a apporté est-ce qu'il
est informé ensuite rapidement de
difficultés qui sont apparues
monsieur le Président traditionnellement
il y a des points de rencontre entre mon
directeur de cabinet et le directeur de
cabinet de mon livre de tutelles c'est à
cette occasion qu'ils échangent sur à la
fois des comptes rendus ou des demandes
ou des des feedbacks si j'ose dire
d'activités menées par mon cabinet
donc le coin qui nous a vous le savez
qui chagrine tout le monde en réalité y
compris les géants c'est qu'il n'y a eu
aucune grille de notation pour la
sélection des projets en réalité
on a pratiqué comme s'il s'agissait de
financement à la main du politique
et non pas d'un appel à projet un appel
à projet alors vous avez de cette
assistance vous l'avez compris vous le
savez beaucoup d'anciens maires
d'anciens présidents de département etc
j'en passe de collectivité alors
lorsqu'une municipalité lance un appel à
projet
elle est tenue par des règles
sur un appel à projet et notamment
les appels à projets
débauche sur plusieurs points qui sont
assez clairs d'abord comment dire un
comité assez ouvert assez large
souvent on recommande que le maire
d'ailleurs ne préside pas bon c'est une
prudence bon et puis ensuite il y a
forcément une grille de notation et qui
est ensuite qui donne lieu à une
communication et généralement un retour
vers les associations ou ou les
entreprises quand il s'agit
d'entreprises non sélectionnées
alors dans ce cas précis
le point qui est extraordinaire c'est
qu'il y a rien
rien alors comment il y avait rien on a
redemandé plusieurs fois parce que ça
dit rien c'est pas possible il y a un
truc enfin bon on distribue pas de
l'argent public sans faire un petit
rapport
un écrit d'un rapport il y a même pas
sur le comité de sélection il y a même
pas un rapport simple que il y a juste
une liste d'associations avec le montant
retenu et en plus nous le savons ce
montant il a été fait sur Excel pour
dire les choses et il a pu être même
modifié après le comité sélection nous y
reviendrons donc on est sur quelque
chose de totalement alors quand l'hygia
a dit que c'est pas transparent
la transparence ça se traduit par tout
simplement à minima par un compte-rendu
qui précise les choses qui précisent les
éléments qui ont les ventes
différenciation on met en place une
grille différenciation on explique etc
généralement aussi il y a un règlement
administratif qui démarre c'est à dire
que avant de répondre à la question
est-ce que vous pouvez c'est est-ce que
vous êtes en situation et donc c'est
toutes les règles administratives c'est
la question de Vincent et Blais sur
l'ancienneté de l'association etc toutes
ces questions sont généralement dans une
première partie et si l'association les
entreprises parce que pour les Mairies
c'est les entreprises souvent si on
franchise cap on peut ensuite
effectivement
être parti prenante de l'appel d'offre
bon voilà dans ce cas précis
c'est pas du tout le cas rien de rien de
rien de rien de rien
alors vous pouvez dire madame je sais
pas comment vous l'avez dit un peu comme
vous avez à votre façon lorsque vous
avez reçu le rapport de l'hygiène que
vous avez commenté le rapport de l'igéa
au-delà du fait que vous prenez la
garantie de dire que vous ne le
commentez pas mais la précaution logique
mais de fait vous dites
en gros le rapport de déjà dit que je
n'ai rien à me reprocher
bon donc
en réalité vous avez un moment donné en
combien de sélection dans lequel il y a
la moitié des membres qui sont de votre
cabinet qui participent à une sélection
qui ne donne lieu à aucun document de
restitution qui ne donne lieu à aucun
élément d'appréciation du choix des
associations qui ne donne même pas lieu
à une analyse préalable permettant de
dire à ce que telle ou telle association
peut répondre on a bien compris que le
premier projet
l'uspm c'est un premier projet entre
guillemets Sifaoui
comment dire abriter par l'uspm en
réalité
il fallait que ce soit une association
qui réponde et pas une personne physique
et donc l'uspm apparaît tout d'un coup
dans le paysage bon il faut voilà mais
on met pas en cause l'uspm on regarde
pas c'est comment dire ces statues on
regarde pas
financier ses capacités à faire on ne
regarde rien et on fait même sujet pour
reconstruire le commun ou en réalité on
est sur une association qui vient de
démarrer qui n'a aucun passé et qui rien
que pour ça pour ces raisons-là n'aurait
pu jamais pu
pouvoir trouver ailleurs ou peut-être ou
que ce soit plus de 300.000 euros de
subventions ça n'existe nulle part et
c'est bien le sujet donc on a bien
là-dessus
excusez-moi de le dire
est-ce que vous considérez après
maintenant en voyant le résultat de tout
ça est-ce que vous considérez que cette
absence d'outils objective
d'appréciation et normal
est-ce que vous trouvez normal qu'il n'y
ait aucun
compte-rendu de réaliser
ni même un relevé de décision argumenté
rien du tout est-ce que ça vous paraît
de bonnes pratiques et est-ce habituel
dans les administrations que vous
connaissez
merci monsieur le Président je
j'identifie quatre questions au moins
voir 5 et je vais essayer d'être
concise
la première chose d'abord bien sûr
souscrit à ce que vous disiez monsieur
le Président sur la constitution des
attributions de subventions dans les
collectivités j'ai eu l'honneur d'être
adjointe au sénateur maire du Mans
pendant quelques années j'avais moi-même
à attribuer des subventions
absolument mer adjointe auprès de
Jean-Claude Boulard qui était sénateur
mergement et j'avais moi-même créé un
Comité d'attribution des subventions
très larges pour justement balayer les
subventions qui avaient pas de pouvoir
de décision mais qui avait encore de
consultation qui était ensuite transmis
à l'administration sous ma présidence
je veux dire cependant qui n'existe à ma
connaissance pas de règles écrites sur
la composition des comités de sélection
d'appels à projets et donc à ce
moment-là de mon point de vue nous
sommes en toute bonne foi dans le
respect des règles de financement et des
règles écrites qui existent dans dans ce
cadre les membres de mon cabinet qui
sont membres du comité de sélection vous
voulez que j'aille plus vite
les membres de mon cabinet qui sont dans
le comité de sélection sont pour deux
d'entre eux des anciens membres du cipdr
ils ont travaillé ils sont experts de
ces questions reconnus et c'est pourquoi
il me semble pas incohérent à ce moment
là de bonne foi une fois encore que
c'est conseillé capé sur le sujet qui
connaissent l'écosystème participent et
travaillent avec ce comité la paix il a
pour nous un cadre d'éligibilité c'est
le cadre et les conditions de la paix
qui est publiée que chacun a qui était
public il prévoit pas effectivement vous
avez tout à fait raison monsieur le
Président de notification de refus en
revanche chaque projet a fait l'objet
d'une fiche que vous avez eu
d'évaluation de son projet qui
synthétise me semble le dossier et bien
évidemment
en retour d'expérience et alors c'est à
posteriori eu égard à tous les éléments
dont nous disposons aujourd'hui bien
évidemment il y a des règles même si
elles ne sont pas des règles de droit
qui sont des usages ou des bonnes
pratiques qu'ils pourraient être utile
de clarifier et c'est pourquoi je vous
disais dans mon propos liminaire je suis
très demandeuse des retours d'expérience
et des préconisations que fera votre
commission d'enquête y compris est
aujourd'hui chargé de la vie associative
et donc quelque part de l'encadrement
des liens entre l'administration et
l'État et les associations si nous
pouvons clarifier peut-être par du
réglementaire les règles d'organisation
de communauté de sélection afin d'aller
vers plus de transparence et de ne pas
être dans l'usuel mais dans le règlement
je pense que ça serait tout à fait
précieux c'est en tout cas mon avis vous
avez parlé de fiche d'évaluation sur
chacune des ça c'est pas tout ce qu'on a
eu nous c'est des fiches de description
de projet et ensuite il y avait une
évaluation qui était faite par la
chargée de mission devant le comité de
sélection évidemment je pense que cela a
eu lieu mais nous n'avons pas
connaissance mais on peut imaginer qu'il
y a eu de la part du site PDR un exposé
sur chaque cas
ça a dû être fait bien entendu parce que
sinon alors
on qui ressort quoi donc voilà donc
forcément il y a eu quelque chose de
cette nature mais
j'insiste sur ce point des fonds d'État
c'est autre chose que des fois
associatifs municipaux les fonds
associatives municipaux ça peut se
régler d'ailleurs assez vite si ça crée
des histoires et des scandales si vous
voulez le maire et et à quelques
difficultés à être réélu voyez ce que je
veux dire donc il y a des précautions
qui sont prises souvent dans les
collectivités surtout ces aspects pour
être bien au clair parce qu'il y a rien
de pire les mères le savent qu'une
association sportive qui dit mais
celle-là a eu je sais pas
les seuls commentaires que nous avons pu
avoir sur sur ces questions c'est la
question que finalement ces associations
qui ont eu moins été considérés comme
souvent par comme un peu gentillesse
vous voyez c'est à dire ayant une vision
de la laïcité comment dire douce
travaillant plutôt sur comment dire
l'esprit de fraternité que sur comment
dire un discours plus
plus raide par rapport au sujet un peu
tel que finalement vous l'avez pas que
vous mais globalement tant que
politiquementale poussez mais ce qui ce
qui chagrine souvent ces associations
qui ont eu des baisses souvent la
motivation orale qui a pu être donné ici
ou là c'était effectivement que c'était
considéré comme pas tout à fait dans la
vision budget
il y a même une fiche qui le dit de
manière explicite mais vous voyez assez
associations là rien ne leur a été
répondu après tout une position
politique de cette nature peut tout à
fait s'exprimer
et une ligne politique a été clairement
affichée par le gouvernement et donc
après tout dire vous n'êtes plus vous
n'êtes pas aujourd'hui finalement dans
cette ligne que nous voulons pousser à
travers ça peut s'entendre mais comme
c'est pas dit
on sait pas si c'est le fait du prince
ou autre chose
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
monsieur le Président sincèrement j'ai
pas d'éléments à partager sur ce sujet
j'ai pas fait partie de ces discussions
moi je trouve pas que ce soit négatif de
soutenir une association qui défendent
les principes de fraternité ça fait
partie des valeurs de la République de
la trilogie républicaine je j'ai en tout
cas formulé aucune demande en ce sens et
j'ai pas connaissance d'échanges qui
peuvent exister visant à dire qu'on va
baisser une demande pour ces raisons
donc en tout cas nous vous l'apprenons
ça a pu être le cas
donc quelles sont les raisons qui vous
ont conduit à exclure un certain nombre
d'associations lors de la sélection des
projets
alors on a dit certaines étaient
totalement hors jeu enfin ne répondez
pas au sujet elles étaient très
nombreuses d'autres c'est un peu plus
délicat et notamment on revient à ça
est-ce que finalement mais vous
m'envoyez répondu alors bon je peux m'en
tenir à ça est-ce que finalement le fait
de pas être dans la ligne
gouvernementale telle qu'elle est
définie publiquement il y a rien de
secret sur la ligne elle l'affichage bon
fait que certaines associations ne
répondent plus finalement même si elle
travaille sur la laïcité ne répondent
plus à vos demandes en tout cas elle ne
correspondent pas à l'esprit du fond
Marianne
monsieur le Président je vais vous
répondre dans mon point de vue à cet
égard mais qui ne présage pas des enfin
qui ne signifient rien au regard des
discussions d'arbitrage parce que une
fois encore je n'ai pas participé au
comité de sélection en revanche je veux
distinguer deux choses je distinguer
l'action politique du gouvernement et la
ligne de politique publique mise en
oeuvre
il est tout à fait permis
j'allais dire recommander j'aurais
peut-être jusque là mais en tout cas
elle est tout à fait permise à des
associations d'être en désaccord avec la
politique gouvernementale et d'ailleurs
je dans les ministères dont j'ai eu la
charge j'en ai financé et j'en finance
encore et c'est en aucun cas un motif de
diminution de demandes de subvention par
rapport à ces associations ça c'est pour
l'action politique ensuite en termes de
politique publique et donc non
politicienne il y a là effectivement une
volonté de travailler à la lutte contre
la radicalisation et donc à défendre les
valeurs de la République et donc par
nature mais encore une fois j'ai pas
participé aux discussions mais je dis ça
pour éclairer ce qui à mon avis peut
procéder à cela je vous donne un exemple
une association qui dirait que il y a
que le l'État français est un état
raciste structurellement je considère
qu'il serait difficile de lui confier
l'action de porter un discours
républicain en ligne qui vise à défendre
les institutions et la République c'est
un exemple que je vous donne un avis
politique personnel que je vous donne
aujourd'hui pour éclairer peut-être les
discussions mais qui ne ça ne veut pas
dire que ce soit ça qui était qui était
discuté je sais pas si je suis claire
dans vous êtes toujours clair madame
merci
tout ceci voyez aurait mérité
parce que ce que vous dites n'est pas
scandaleux
en mérité une précision un éclairage et
d'un rapport que ce soit écrit il y a
pas de il y a pas de difficulté ce n'est
pas le cas donc tout peut être interrogé
je voudrais évidemment revenir
sur un sujet que vous connaissez
donc vous avez été informé et et quand
notamment citer votre directeur de
cabinet qui est un point important qui
est finalement la suppression d'une
subvention à une association qui est
depuis a été cité par la presse elle
n'avait pas été un audition mais c'est
SOS Racisme
et simplement vous dire qu'il y a
là-dessus plusieurs aspects qui sont
étonnants
et quelquefois un peu choquant
le premier c'est que
le 25 mai a lieu le comité de sélection
le 25 mai et le 27 mai il y a un mail de
votre membre de votre cabinet
au préfet Gravel en disant j'ai soumis à
la ministre votre note on fait le point
demain
votre note c'est à dire la note
concernant le comité de sélection de la
de la veille
ou de jours avant et juste après vous
prenez une décision qui est prise par
vous selon votre directeur de cabinet
qui est de supprimer une ligne
budgétaire du comité de sélection qui
est celle concernant SOS Racisme je
crois que c'est à hauteur de 100.000
euros de mémoire et qui était elle dans
le comité de sélection donc si on a
parlé des problématiques avant le comité
de sélection on a parlé des
problématiques durant le comité de
sélection mais même après le comité de
sélection combien notre il y a toujours
pas de compte rendu du comité de
sélection
en réalité le comité de sélection
je ne sais pas si sélectionne on sait
plus puisque à la sortie comme vous
dites vous validez mais en fait quand
vous validez le résultat du comité de
sélection en réalité vous influez sur le
résultat vous influencer le résultat en
supprimant et et votre directeur de
cabinet a une expression particulière en
indiquant que c'est suite d'ailleurs à
des questions personnelles entre
l'expression et pas exactement celle là
mais l'esprit c'est cela
passé entre vous et l'association en
question est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire
comment les choses se passent dans cette
affaire là si Monsieur le Directeur de
Cabinet Monsieur le Préfet a eu
à raison de présenter les choses ainsi
est-ce que vous dites non c'est pas le
cas enfin qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça
bien sûr monsieur le Président je vous
remercie de me poser la question et me
permettre justement d'apporter des
éléments de d'éclairage je répondrai à
tous les points sans exception d'abord
je vais être très clair je n'ai pas
supprimé de subventions à SOS Racisme je
dis pas que c'est ce que vous avez dit
mais j'ai vu des réponses qui ont été
portées en ce sens disant que mes
décisions auraient mis en péril un
équilibre financier d'une association je
rappelle qu'on est sur un appel à projet
on parle pas de financement ni de
fonctionnement pour les associations
donc je n'enlève pas de l'argent à SOS
racisme dont il bénéficierait chaque
année
alors je vais je vais y revenir mais en
tout cas premier élément
c'est subtil comme réponse je pense que
le droit emporte monsieur le Président
d'une part et d'autre part au-delà du
droit quand la réalité est aussi là
c'est à dire vous n'attribuez pas 100000
euros qui avait été sélectionnés
entendu très bien chacun
je vais vous répondre en essayant d'être
le plus factuel possible dans la mesure
où à titre personnel je n'avais aucun
souvenir du fait qu'il y ait eu des
discussions sur SOS Racisme dans le
cadre du fond Marianne
maintenant qu'on a appelé ce sujet à mon
attention j'ai souvenir qu'il y ait eu
des échanges sur SOS Racisme je me base
sur les faits et sur les échanges écrits
que j'ai pu trouver pour rétablir une
chronologie ce qu'on me ce que je
comprends aujourd'hui ce qu'on me dit
c'est qu'il y a une liste établie par le
comité de sélection du fond Marianne
avec des dossiers qui font l'unanimité
du comité de sélection et avec certains
qui sont entre guillemets en liste
complémentaire c'est-à-dire pour débat
je comprends de ce qu'on me dit
aujourd'hui que SOS Racisme fait partie
de cette liste complémentaire et qu'il
n'y a pas consensus au sein du comité de
sélection et qu'il y a divergences
certains considérant qui ne faut pas
attribuer cette subvention et d'autres
considérants au contraire qu'il faut
attribuer cette subvention le point mais
m'excusant c'est pas le compte enfin
c'est pas le compte-rendu que nous avons
du préfet le préfet nous dit j'ai
simplement demandé
qu'il y ait une réserve sur ce dossier
pour pouvoir vous en parler
personnellement c'est pas la même chose
que de dire qu'il y a un désaccord il y
a pas de désaccord il y a simplement une
précaution de vérification auprès de
vous d'un accord sur le fait qu'on voilà
je comprends bien que ce n'est pas la
même chose Monsieur le Président mais
moi c'est la version que j'ai
aujourd'hui et que je partage avec vous
aujourd'hui d'après ce qu'on me dit
d'après ce que je retrouve dans les
échanges ce qu'on vous dit Madame c'est
ce que vous savez quand même vous
oubliez pas tout de votre vie quand même
je veux dire monsieur le Président mais
en deux ans j'ai eu à présider un
certain nombre de réunions à rendre un
certain arbitrage et surtout je ne peux
pas me souvenir de réunion auquel je
n'ai pas participé donc l'IGA ou
vous-même ou peut-être même la justice
établiront ce qu'il en est moi je porte
à votre connaissance le fait que
aujourd'hui j'ai une note sur une
question de justice dans ce cas précis
on est juste sur comprendre
mais moi j'essaye de partager avec vous
les éléments que je recoupe je comprends
cela et le point mais remontées par mon
conseiller spécial par un mail ça s'est
établi je l'ai dans lequel il a il me
fait une note que vous avez si vous
n'avez pas vous la passer dans laquelle
il me fait une note en disant voilà ce
sur quoi nous sommes d'accord et
signaler le dossier de SOS raciste qui
manifestement ne trouve pas de consensus
il me demande à moi du coup de trancher
de rendre un arbitrage de donner un avis
favorable ou défavorable au projet
je pense qu'il sur la question là il se
complémentaire ils sont en liste
complémentaire avant la réunion du
comité de sélection
à la sortie du comité de sélection ils
sont sélectionnés je ne sais pas
actuellement vous faites partie du
comité de sélection je vous le rappelle
vous êtes fait représenter pour des
raisons qui vous sont propres
du comité de sélection juridiquement en
tant que ministre vous faites partie du
comité de sélection comme vous le disiez
monsieur le rapporteur le droit est
important la réalité aussi est
réellement je ne suis pas dans le comité
de sélection je n'ai pas dit que vous
aviez siéger je dis simplement que
juridiquement voilà vous avez vous aviez
pris des disposition pour être membre du
comité de sélection alors en tout cas on
me demande un arbitrage on me demande un
avis pour trancher un sujet qui
manifestement d'après ce que j'en
comprends en tout cas ne fait pas
consensus je donne cet avis et il me
semble que le ministre est fondé a donné
un avis favorable ou défavorable quand
son administration ou son cabinet le lui
demande je ne rends pas mon avis tout de
suite
ce dont je dispose je demande une note
sur le projet ce qui démontre bien je ne
rends pas un avis sur une personne et
j'y reviendrai je demande une note sur
le projet pour qu'on puisse voir de quoi
il s'agit dans les notes que j'ai à ma
disposition et vous également
aujourd'hui le projet proposé par
l'association SOS racis qui est par
ailleurs une association tout à fait
respectable et partenaire de l'État et
de différents ministères et encore
aujourd'hui et récemment il est proposé
une action en deux temps l'une sur les
réseaux sociaux et donc qui correspond à
l'objet du fond Marianne et l'autre et
c'est pourquoi je répondais tout à
l'heure à la question de Monsieur
sénateur concerne me semble-t-il des
activités sportives ou physiques dans
certains quartiers or cette proposition
d'action qui vise des qrr c'est à dire
40 quartiers de reconquête républicaine
et donc pas le champ national
contrairement à ce qui est demandé dans
l'appel à projet c'est une action qui
est déjà menée et déjà financée par des
fonds du FIPD par une autre organ
situation qui s'appelle raid aventure et
qui fait exactement ce travail de
cohésion de prévention dans les
quartiers
qrr par le biais d'activités sportives
et donc j'imagine que c'est cela qui
amène à ce moment-là a considérer que
l'activité étant or réseau sociaux pour
par importante et de surcroît déjà
couvertes par une autre association
j'aimais manifestement j'en ai pas
souvenir mais manifestement j'ai mis un
avis défavorable en disant que pour moi
ce n'est pas un projet à retenir c'est
un avis que j'aimais et ensuite le
comité de sélection fait une liste
d'après les éléments dont je dispose
dans laquelle de figure pas SOS Racisme
je veux répondre à un élément qui est
fondamental sur ce sujet sur ce qu'a dit
Monsieur le Préfet j'allais qui est un
homme en qui j'ai toute confiance qui a
été mon directeur de cabinet à qui je
referai conscience à l'avenir si j'étais
amené à devoir le faire et qui est un
grand préfet mais mon ancien directeur
de cabinet
feta de relations personnelles de
désaccord personnel que j'aurais avec
monsieur le Président des SOS Racisme je
n'ai pas là non plus on me prête
beaucoup de relations personnelles mais
je n'ai pas de relation personnelle ni
de désaccord personnel ancien ou récent
avec monsieur le Président de SOS
racistes nous avons des désaccords sur
des points madame la ministre je vous
arrête parce que le temps court et qu'il
faut avancer
mais reconnaissez que il y a quelque
chose qui va pas vous nous racontez
votre vision des choses
on vous entend
très bien mais nous celles que l'on a
n'est pas la même donc quand vous dites
d'abord comme vous dites
le préféré etc j'ai parfaitement
confiance à lui mais il a dit des choses
qui sont fausses globalement c'est ce
que vous dites je ne dis pas que ce sont
des choses fausses mais c'est une
présence
je pense que c'est une interprétation de
sa part ou incompréhension peut-être de
ma faute peut-être de choses que j'ai
exprimé auprès de nos directeur de
cabinet qui l'amène à penser que j'ai un
antérieur personnel avec le président de
SOS racistes ce n'est pas le cas en tout
cas
la question est quand même beaucoup plus
excusez moi de vous le dire beaucoup
plus simple il y a un comité de
sélection à l'entrée du comité de
sélection il y a des dossiers qui posent
pas de problème on va dire
il y a une liste supplémentaire à la
sortie du comité de sélection il y a
plus de liste supplémentaires c'est
terminé il y a un choix qui a été fait
par le comité de sélection et à ce
moment-là ils sont un peu l'imaginer
dit
attention je fais une réserve sur un des
dossiers de comité de sélection retenu
donc un des dossiers retenus je fais une
réserve parce que je souhaite le
soumettre à la ministre bon alors deux
éléments derrière le premier c'est que
effectivement la remarque qui est faite
c'est une remarque de nature personnelle
et pas une remarque de nature
professionnelle donc ça vous dites le
préfet j'allais à une mauvaise
compréhension du sujet vous n'avez pas
au-delà de ça bon enfin il y a un sujet
peut-être de ma faute j'ai pu être
maladroit dans mon expression c'est tout
à fait possible
enfin tout de même je vais je vais très
précis madame la ministre je vous ai
effectivement expliqué les montants donc
on a le 20 mai
il y a une note de la chargée de mission
qui est envoyé au cabinet donc vous
n'êtes pas très éloigné qui indique que
le projet pourrait SOS Racisme est
d'accorder 100000 euros je rappelle
puisqu'il y avait questionnement que la
demande initiale était de 140.000 euros
et le premier juin il y a un membre de
votre cabinet qui a adressé un mail
indiquant que lors d'une réunion tenue
le même jour donc le 1er juin il a été
décidé de retirer à SOS Racisme
c'est 100.000 euros et de verser 100 -
80 on sait pas pourquoi 20 000 euros au
profit d'une autre association l'effet
la matérialité des faits c'est ça et
uniquement ça
voilà et puis surtout sur l'idée de
voyez bien que sa mère en difficulté
votre position sur finalement
j'ai laissé travailler le comité de
sélection alors c'est vrai dans une
certaine mesure à part qu'il y a eu des
choses qui ont été faites en amont on
l'a dit des choses qui sont faites
pendant le comité de sélection sur
certaines associations qui sont jugées
trop
trop faible enfin en tout cas ne
répondons pas à l'exigence
gouvernementale je vous dis que ce
point-là était
pouvait être entendu et puis ensuite à
la fin à l'après le comité de sélection
alors que la liste est établie et bien
on vient retirer à une association un
montant et ça vient si vous voulez
contredire d'une certaine façon alors
l'idée de dire moi mon rôle c'était de
dire voilà le comité de sélection
sélectionne ce qu'on pouvait entendre
parce que votre vous étiez représenté
par votre cabinet déjà dans le comité de
sélection donc
sélection sélectionne et moi je valide
et bien non
vous n'avez pas validé la vie du comité
de sélection vous avez dit sur une
association ça me convient pas alors
est-ce que le préfet Jallet s'est trompé
dans son interprétation
ou est-ce qu'il faut retenir votre état
de prétentation voilà d'une certaine
façon
n'étant pas là c'est pas nous qui
pouvons mais on note une autre quelque
chose de différent voilà monsieur le
Président je pourrais être très clair je
ne dis pas que je n'ai pas donné d'avis
sur SOS Racisme j'ai manifestement donné
un avis négatif sur le projet des SOS
Racisme avis qu'on m'a demandé là où je
dis qu'il y a une différence
d'interprétation
avait déjà eu lieu et que vous
avez été opéré et que vous rangiez à la
vie du comité de sélection vous n'aviez
pas donné un avis sur les les finalement
les associations déjà sélectionnées
monsieur le président
je demande mon avis
non mais je ne m'immise pas dans le
comité de sélection on vient requérir un
arbitrage ministériel sur un sujet en
particulier et sur un seul donc je ne
prends pas part je le répète je ne
prends pas part au comité de sélection à
aucun moment je n'y siège pas et je ne
donne pas de consigne la meilleure
preuve en est c'est qu'on me remonte
pour habiter j'avais donné des consignes
chacun aurait mes consignes en tête là
on me remonte pour arbitrage ou pour
avis favorable ou défavorable je donne
un avis et c'est à l'issue de cet avis
que la décision est prise ça se passe
toujours ainsi après la réunion du
comité de sélection il y a une liste et
dans cette liste ne figure pas
l'association des SOS Racisme après
études du projet
on a
essayé de donner la matérialité des
faits le déroulement
vous vous tenez à l'écart mais vous
gardez un regard et même une capacité de
décider les choses sont finalement plus
claires comme ça c'est une manière de
reconnaître que vous avez un pouvoir de
décision tout en vous tenant à l'écart
vous êtes présente pour décider voilà
vous avez
vous avouer
avoir un rôle et une capacité à décider
et à trancher mais c'est mieux de le
dire que de tournicoter autour d'une
décision en expliquant que vous y êtes
mais pas tout à fait vous êtes à côté
c'est logique c'est de ça relève de
votre responsabilité le comité de
sélection comprend pour la moitié des
membres de votre cabinet c'est
parfaitement logique on vous on pourrait
vous reprocher l'inverse bien sûr ce
sont monsieur le rapporteur deux choses
différentes ce n'est pas que je tourne
autour c'est que je tiens à être précise
et si ce n'est pas
je ne sais pas par opposition à
vous-même je permettrais pas de
vous êtes précis monsieur le rapporteur
vos questions sont précises bien
évidemment je tâche de l'être aussi sur
la base des faits dont j'ai souvenir ou
que j'ai matériellement je ne je ne suis
pas dans le comité de sélection mais
quand on demande un avis au ministre le
ministre donne un avis là encore s'il
lui fallut procéder autrement et que
dans les dans les retours d'expérience
et dans les recommandations ou
préconisations que vous ferez vous
considérer que le ministre ne doit pas
rendre un avis ou un arbitrage quand il
lui est demandé sur des subventions
c'est tout à fait entendable et pourquoi
pas mais à ce stade on vient je ne vais
pas d'initiative au comité de sélection
me remonter on me demande un avis je
demande qu'on regarde le projet et je
donne un avis et ensuite le comité
établit une liste finale et je rappelle
que seul le cipdr est fond à mettre les
crédits en paiement ou à attribuer une
finie les subventions de ceux qui font
le périmètre de votre ministère vous
avez la signature donc c'est le ministre
ou la ministre qui décide je veux
revenir sur les dossiers de demande de
subvention qui ont été déposés
préalablement à l'appel à projet parce
que ça nous a fait un peu sortir de de
l'appel à projet certains ont été
validés lors du comité de programmation
du 13 avril validé
et ensuite pour certains d'entre eux ils
ont été basculés dans le fond Marianne
dont je rappelle qu'il est mis en place
officiellement le 20 avril
au final est-ce que c'est pas d'une
certaine manière contraire à l'esprit
qui préside à la création du fond
Marianne dont l'objectif est de lutter
contre toutes les formes de séparatisme
notamment par la voie digitale et
numérique
je comprends pas le sens de votre
question parce que la question vous avez
des dossiers qui sont validés dans le
comité de programmation du 13 avril ça
veut dire que c'était plutôt du gré
c'est ce que vous avez expliqué le vin
avril vous lancez le fond Marianne et
par un tour je sais pas si elle passe
une analyse très aboutie enfin certains
des dossiers qui avaient été retenus
dans le je dis bien retenu dans le
comité programmation du 13 avril
finalement bascule ensuite dans le fond
Marianne or l'esprit du fond Marianne il
est aussi différent il est de faire
autrement d'identifier des acteurs
associatifs
sur des actions nouvelles alors ça peut
les actions des acteurs associatifs
anciens ou nouveau mais vous en avez qui
viennent d'obtenir un accord sur la
communauté de programmation
vous voyez c'est la raison pour laquelle
quand je vous disais le bilan est en
demi teinte on a l'impression qu'il y a
dû rattrapage enfin ça manque de
lisibilité et de force en tous les cas
dans le dans le projet me semble-t-il
non
votre question c'est savoir si je trouve
que ça manque de lisibilité dans le
processus
de l'esprit oui enfin je sais pas
comment il faut que je vous pose la
question
non monsieur rapporteur à ce moment-là
moi je suis pas dans les réunions qui
décident de passer tel association de
d'un financement habituel à un appel à
projet ou qui leur propose de le faire
néanmoins
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas choquée par
le fait que on est des acteurs avec
lesquels on travaille habituellement et
qu'on les flèche vers l'appel à projet
c'est la question
je trouve que je vous ai senti beaucoup
plus parfois
motivé et convaincu je trouve que là
vous êtes plutôt sur la mer un faux plat
parce que il y a un vrai mélange qui ne
sert pas la cause pour laquelle le fond
Marianne a été mis en oeuvre en tous les
cas moi c'est ce que j'en ai compris
après coup puisque je l'avais pas suivi
de très près au départ voilà je pense
qu'il y a un problème de ligne
directrice vous avez un sujet avec le
secteur associatif qui n'est évidemment
pas forcément facile
à mettre en action parce que on a
compris la complexité du label de l'État
qui a des difficultés
de communiquer et de pénétrer voilà
ces milieux qui ne sont pas conformes je
dirais à l'esprit des valeurs de la
République mais entre tout ça pour moi
on sent du cafouillage du mélange des
genres et j'ai encore à cette heure-ci
j'essaie de suivre votre parcours mais
je peux vous avouer parfois entre vous
le cabinet le cpdr des fonctionnaires
qui sont entrés dans votre cabinet mais
qui sont donc dans le cabine mais qui
sont les anciens fonctionnaires et puis
tout le processus se déroule avec le
fond Marianne mise en oeuvre enfin
officiellement annoncé le 20 avril
terminé le 10 mai à comité de sélection
qui sélectionne mais la ministre peut et
je l'entends mais on a une difficulté
parce que vous nous dites que vous tenez
à l'écart mais quand même vous rendez
des décisions de revenir sur au moins
une décision du comité de sélection je
voudrais juste savoir si c'est une
procédure assez habituelle ou si c'était
un cas unique par rapport à votre
expérience
sur le rapporteur je trouve que chacun
est en réalité dans son rôle c'est à
dire que le ministre impulse la
politique publique la représente la
défend
on est en et le garant on rencontre ce
que je fais aujourd'hui devant vous et
que je fais à d'autres
occasions et que l'administration
ensuite met en oeuvre suit administré le
fait qu'il y a des membres de cabinet
qui soit antérieurement membres
d'administration oui c'est très
classique et l'administration
aujourd'hui et remplie de remplir en
tout cas il y a beaucoup dans
l'administration d'anciens membres de
cabinets ce sont des des trajectoires de
carrière classique oui
madame la ministre
alors des questions sur le suivi de
manière assez rapide d'abord votre
implication dans le suivi de la
réalisation des projets par les
différentes associations est-ce que vous
avez rencontré certaines d'entre elles
dans la pour vous tenir informé c'est
dans le suivi de trucs ou pas du tout
est-ce que vous considérez c'était
l'administration qui devait suivre pas
vous avez vous revu monsieur Sifaoui
dans la phase
discutée en tout cas aujourd'hui vous le
savez sur la réalisation
est-ce que vous avez été est-ce que vous
avez eu des remontées de difficultés
rencontrez avec certaines associations
durant la période où vous étiez au
ministère
monsieur le Président ne remonte je n'ai
aucune remontée de difficultés
d'association d'aucune sorte jusqu'à
l'article du journal Marianne avant cela
et cresson avant cela pendant toute la
durée du moment où je suis ministre
c'est à dire jusqu'en mai 2022 à aucun
moment on ne fait état d'aucune
difficulté rencontrée avec les
associations donc le ministre n'est pas
en charge du contrôle des associations
il y a un contrôle qui manifestement est
effectué c'est ce qui établisse les
différentes déclarations des uns et des
autres en tout cas ce n'est pas le
ministre qui procède à ce contrôle et il
n'y a auprès de moi aucune remontée
d'aucune difficulté de mise en œuvre
avec ses associations
comment dire
oui en droit
vous avez c'est possible ce que vous
dites est possible et si vous le dites
sincèrement c'est vrai
mais ce qui est étonnant
là où on a un a du mal c'est si vous
voulez c'est pas une opération comme les
autres
c'est bien pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il y a
un débat national un peu là-dessus mais
pour ça qu'il y a des gens qui qui
s'intéressent à ce sujet qui s'interroge
c'est que c'est pas un débat lorsque
lorsqu'on vous faites par exemple vous
subventionnez des associations dans le
cadre du du fond de la prévention de la
délinquance à l'essentiel des montants
il n'y a pas derrière de connotation il
y a pas de sujet lorsqu'on est sur le
fond Marianne vous vous auriez pu pour
dire les choses autrement vous aviez
déjà des dépenses qui concernaient le
sujet vous auriez pu dire j'augmente les
budgets j'ai demandé à mon
administration de mettre plus d'argent
sur ces sur ces moyens liés finalement à
la réponse sur les réseaux sociaux
ça pouvait être ça et c'était un des
éléments de votre plan tout à fait pas
de problème et ça aurait soulevé aucune
question mais vous allez sur les
plateaux télé vous faites des interviews
sur le fond de mariage et vous faites le
lien entre ce qui s'est passé en octobre
2020 et le fond mariage et du coup vous
connotez votre action ça devient une
action
qui socialement a du sens qui répond à
des angoisses des français quand même ce
qui s'est passé n'est pas rien et vous
faites une réponse politique argumentée
en mettant ce fond Marianne ne vous
étonnez pas après que tout le monde
s'intéresse à qu'est-ce que c'est devenu
le fond Marianne parce que c'est pas une
subvention du fi PDR c'est
c'est une subvention fléchée du qui est
pas présenté comme ça qui est présenté
comme la création d'un fond et qui liée
à une histoire et bien cette histoire
d'une certaine façon elle appelle et ce
qui m'étonne dans votre réponse je vous
le dis c'est que vous ne dites pas pour
démarrer ma responsabilité je reviens
toujours nous on est il y a pas de
culpabilité chez nous il y a de la
responsabilité
de la responsabilité de lui vous avez la
responsabilité vous avez fait naître une
idée un concept une réponse politique et
derrière vous nous dites je la suis pas
c'est ça que vous venez de me répondre
je viens de vous le dire et c'est grave
ça vous nous dites c'est
l'administration l'administration est
chargé de charger de regarder que
financièrement les choses se passent
bien ça c'est pas votre problème mais
quand même le contenu les éléments
est-ce que ça sert à quelque chose
ça c'est vous quoi et vous l'avez même
d'ailleurs dit vous-même vous portez les
politiques publiques et si on regarde ce
que vous avez porté comme politique
publique à ce moment-là je dirais
presque c'est pas pour des questions de
mon temps mais pour des questions de
contenu c'est vous qui c'est le fond
Marianne qui qui est finalement votre
action symbolique et il y a rien de pire
que le symbole quand on est sur des
actions symboliques il faut qu'elle
marche du feu de dieu faut que ça
fonctionne de A à Z et il faut que vous
ayez un regard attentif et là aussi vous
avez ici devant vous des gens qui ont
été élus locaux ils savent que le sujet
sur lequel ils sont pris c'est pas le
sujet qui fait la moitié de leur budget
c'est quelquefois c'est une bricole mais
on va dire mais là pourquoi vous avez
financé tel truc que tu as l'association
et et dites-nous à quoi ça sert
c'est toujours sur les détails et là
vous nous faites une réponse technique
et j'oserais dire madame la ministre qui
manque un peu le cœur
voilà vous avez pas suivi cette affaire
et c'est presque pire que ça quand on va
sur la suite au moment de transmettre à
votre successeur personne n'est au
courant du sujet fabuleux il est même
pas dans le dossier ministre nous
entendons donc du début à la fin on a
l'impression que c'est lancé et une fois
que c'est lancé qu'on a dit voilà ce
qu'on va faire tout le reste
ça vous concerne pas alors j'aimerais
que vous ne répondiez à ça parce que ça
c'est extrêmement dérangeant monsieur le
Président je vais tâcher de vous
répondre
et de changer votre votre impression
même si c'est par nature subjective et
l'impression que vous avez du coeur ou
du de la tonalité que j'utilise pour
pour vous répondre et par nature la
vôtre et parfaitement légitime je veux
commencer par dire que je ne me suis à
aucun moment étonné qu'on s'intéresse à
l'utilisation des crédits du fond
Marianne non seulement je m'en suis pas
étonné ou offusqué mais plus que cela
dès le premier contact avec un
journaliste d'investigation du journal
Marianne sur ce sujet je ne suis plus
membre du gouvernement mais je lui
réponds et je lui réponds que
à ma connaissance ce sont des
informations des demandes d'information
légitimes et que le ministère est fondé
à lui apporter les réponses et
d'ailleurs à ce moment là et je le dis
pour répondre à votre interpellation
monsieur le Président le la journaliste
nous dit qu'elle veut la liste des
bénéficiaires du fond Marianne et je lui
réponds qu'il faut que le ministère la
lui donne parce que à mon sens ce n'est
pas confidentiel et c'est le fait qu'il
y ait un délai pour répondre qui amène à
ce moment-là à dire qu'il y a une
opacité et qu'il y a quelque chose de
sous donc moi je suis non seulement pas
choqué qu'on s'intéresse à
l'organisation du fond Marianne mais
j'en suis demandeuse moi je suis choquée
quand je vois à quel point des missions
qui ont été confiées des attentes fortes
qui ont été portées en toute conscience
vis-à-vis de certains partenaires non en
réalité pas donné lieu à des actions
concrètes derrière tels que l'établi le
rapport de l'hygia bien sûr ça me choque
bien sûr je me sens flouée quand je
découvre cela dans la presse
d'investigation à un moment je ne suis
pas du tout membre du gouvernement à
aucun ministère quand je suis interrogée
ne pas faire les contrôles monsieur le
Président ne signifie pas et pardon je
me suis mal exprimé ne signifie pas que
je ne sois pas intéressé à cette
politique publique ce que je vous dis et
pour répondre le plus factuellement et
rationnellement et matériellement
possible aux questions qui nous sont
posées depuis ce matin sur ce sujet
c'est que j'essaie de vous apporter des
éléments matériels et que non je n'ai
pas suivi l'utilisation des crédits ni
contrôler les associations puisque ce
n'était pas le rôle du ministre ça ne
veut pas dire que je mens des intéresse
il est vrai et juste de dire que j'ai
beaucoup communiqué sur le fond Marianne
je pense pas faux de dire que je
communique beaucoup sur toutes les
politiques publiques que je porte on
peut trouver que c'est bien aussi mal
mais c'est ainsi
l'absence de communication une fois
l'annonce faite de la création du fort
Marianne
quasiment l'absence de communication
jusqu'à votre départ sur la mise en
oeuvre les choix et puis le projet
avance et le gouvernement par ce choix
de lien avec le monde associatif
affirme une volonté la traduit
concrètement deux choses d'abord je
voudrais poursuivre les réponses à
monsieur le Président si vous me le
permettez parce qu'il y a deux sujets
sur lesquels je souhaite pouvoir
apporter des réponses d'abord sur vous
me dites monsieur le Président qu'on
aurait pu renforcer les moyens par
ailleurs en termes de réponse à
l'attentat terrible qui s'est produit en
octobre 2020 je veux dire que les moyens
ils ont été renforcés j'évoquais les
moyens humains de Pharos j'évoquais les
moyens humains de l'ucider je crois pas
avoir du ça alors il me semble sauf si
jamais compris que vous avez dit qu'en
réponse je crée le fond Marianne et que
j'aurais pu plutôt dire en réponse nous
allons augmenter les moyens de faire je
veux dire vous auriez pu le faire de
manière plus discrète si je puis dire
euh simplement dire en termes
d'interview de ou de communication
écouter il y a des fonds qui sont déjà
dédiés à ces opérations on va les
pousser les augmenter et en rester là
sans créer même le nombre de Marianne
vous voyez ce que je veux dire d'accord
à ce moment-là c'était une opération
plus discrète et je vous dirai en
conclusion que je pense que ça aurait
été sans doute une meilleure solution
mais ça se défend parfaitement j'entends
d'ailleurs qu'elle a été débattue je
veux dire au sein du gouvernement et
dans vos services elle a été débattue la
question de savoir s'il fallait
simplement pousser le curseur ou s'il
fallait créer une image voilà et ma
question portait sur tel instant où on
crée une image
c'est comment la fait vivre cette image
je vais aller lourde cette image c'est
ça qui est c'est ça c'est l'événement de
référence qui est lourd voilà et quand
vous voyez et c'est pour ça que je viens
sur cette question qui peut paraître
morale d'une certaine façon mais moi
quand je lis aujourd'hui que la famille
Patty refuse que de lier son nom au fond
Marianne du fait des
discussions en cours ça ça me fait mal
voyez parce que je ça veut dire qu'à un
moment donné il y a eu un abandon de un
abandon du lien relationnel vous voyez
ce que je veux dire et c'est majeur dans
la vie
d'abord monsieur le Président je
d'abord monsieur le Président en ce qui
concerne l'attentat de 2020 je veux dire
que ça ne procède pas à la décision de
lancer une action de contrediscount mais
ça il fait écho parce que je suis très
brève là dessus le terroriste en zorof
le terroriste qui a commis l'attentat
contre le professeur Samuel Passy le
terrible attentat qui a été qui a été
commis il se serait radicalisé disent
les enquêteurs en ligne en consultant
des réseaux sociaux et c'est pourquoi ça
fait co à cette action et ça vient
tristement être dramatiquement illustré
les alertes que les services portent et
la nécessité
d'accélérer et d'avancer sur ce sujet
vous y avez fait directement un lien
quoi voilà bien sûr parce que c'est mise
en s'est mise au regard et c'est hélas
illustration de ce que Gilles appelle le
djihadisme d'atmosphère qui vient de
façon terrible et dramatique être
illustré le discours des Mureaux du
président de la République précèdent à
cela donc c'est un sujet qui est déjà
identifié pour nous des travaux qui sont
lancés sur sur ce sujet à ce moment là
en ce qui concerne le dossier ministre
vous avez parfaitement raison monsieur
le Président le fond Marianne d'après
les éléments que j'ai ni figure pas je
tiens à dire que ce n'est pas le
ministre qui fait le dossier ministre
pour le nouveau ministre qui arrive non
c'est important monsieur le Président on
est d'accord mais ça ça montre quelque
chose ça ça dit quelque chose de
l'importance des choses et l'important
des choses vous l'avez dit c'est vous
qui l'impulsez c'est votre
responsabilité politique d'impulser il y
a des sujets qui vous tiennent à cœur et
sincèrement la laïcité c'est pas la
première fois enfin je veux dire il y a
des années que vous avez terminé sur le
sujet donc il y a pas de il y a pas de
doute sur votre voilà crédibilité sur le
sur ce point mais à un moment donné on
crée un faux Marianne il y a pas de
suivi vous nous dites pendant la période
où vous êtes ministre bon ben c'est le
vous occupez pas enfin vous n'êtes pas
dit je ne m'occupe pas de son mariage
alors si je peux répondre mais vous avez
répondu ça ce qu'on veut dire
de répondre moi je reste très longtemps
si vous voulez mais
l'audition touche à sa fin donc soyez
comme on dirait bon alors
je pense à très respectueuse mais ce
rapporteur dans mes réponses dans le
temps de réponse voilà
mais écoutez simplement dire et je
conçois que ce ne soit pas la réponse
que vous attendiez mais dans
l'interpellation qui m'est faite
avec intérêt merci monsieur le Président
donc je vous ai dit je prends toute ma
responsabilité et rien que ma
responsabilité quand ma successeur est
nommée je ne suis plus au gouvernement
j'ai d'autres activités ailleurs je ne
suis plus fondée à donner des consignes
à l'administration et ce serait le
contraire qu'il serait reproché
la synthèse les questions parce que vous
avez comme je vous ai posé une question
vous êtes revenu sur la question
précédente donc invité si vous voulez
bien les longueurs voilà il y a eu une
forte annonce puissante communication et
après plus rien oui je voulais répondre
bien sûr merci monsieur le rapporteur
simplement vous dire que il n'y avait
pas plus rien il y a matér dans les
échanges de mails entre mon cabinet et
moi-même et des notes dans lesquelles
nous voulons relancer le fond Marianne
il y a une note de projet suite à la
demande de ma part et à échange et suite
justement à discussion avec le cabinet
l'administration sur ce sujet l'un de
mes conseillers prépare un futur appel à
projet pour l'année qui suit sur le fond
Marianne nous voulons nous entendons
poursuivre cette politique publique
d'accord mais donc vous conviendrez et
vous ne m'avez pas démenti qu'il n'y a
pas de communication particulière
après le lancement il y a l'annonce du
fond Marianne il y a la sélection le
projet
vit sa vie il y a plus de communication
voilà il n'a plus une bénéficie plus du
même portage et surtout du même éco
médiatique puisque par l'annonce
l'annonce médias et l'annonce fond
Marianne vous l'avez d'ailleurs expliqué
c'est une ambition politique d'un combat
que vous menez contre le discours
séparatiste en lien avec le numérique et
le secteur associatif voilà je pourrais
très rapide dans ma réponse monsieur le
rapporteur en deux points
je vais essayer encore plus rapide
d'abord c'est pas parce qu'il y a pas de
communication qui a pas de suivi j'ai
des je demande je le dis je ne
désintéresse pas du sujet il y a des
points d'étape que je demande et donc je
ne suis pas les subventions mais je suis
le dossier du fond Marianne première
chose et deuxième chose je n'apprends à
personne le système médiatique et bien
évidemment quand un ministre fait des
annonces qui sont susceptibles de
générer des dépêches et des reprises
cela intéresse les différentes les
différents médias mais quand on veut
communiquer sur des bilans c'est
beaucoup plus c'est beaucoup moins jugé
moins intéressant et c'est plus
difficile de surcroît qu'on les porteurs
de projets ne souhaitent pas apparaître
pour des raisons de sécurité parce que
certains d'entre disent qu'ils sont
assez ça ne nous a pas échappé mais
entre certains et rien du tout
la preuve le fait qu'il n'y ait même pas
de bilan sur un sujet comme celui-ci moi
je je suis je m'inscris parfaitement
dans les propos de Claude Raynal
enfin la gravité de l'acte et la
solennité
de la République
lorsqu'on s'est retrouvé
à la Sorbonne pour manifester
l'unité de la République en faveur de ce
combat je dois dire que je le dis après
le fond Marianne tout ça a perdu
beaucoup de consistance voilà c'est tout
moi
puisqu'on arrive à la fin
finalement à ce stade appel à projet
vous venez d'évoquer les conditions dans
lesquelles il s'était organisé déroulée
sélectionner valider
si c'est à refaire vous feriez la même
chose en mieux vous procéderiez de
quelle manière puisque
peut-être on donnera des orientations à
ce stade étant en responsabilité
toujours et du monde associatif quel est
votre regard
qu'avez-vous à nous dire à cet instant
quelque chose d'abord
effectivement il est vous l'avez dit
nécessaire de resituer le contexte et
vous l'avez fait donc je n'y reviens pas
il y a évidemment des choses qu'on
aurait pu faire différemment dans la
mesure où on arrive aujourd'hui à
commander un rapport à l'iagea vous
arrivez vous-même à lancer une
commission d'enquête et à vous saisir
des prérogatives de contrôle l'action du
Gouvernement par le Parlement
parfaitement légitimement et utilement
sur ce sujet c'est donc il y a eu des
dysfonctionnements dans l'organisation
ou la gestion du fond Marianne moi je
veux être à ce stade prudente pour pas
émettre ici des sentiments ou des
impressions mais je pense qu'il est
effectivement nécessaire d'avoir
peut-être par écrit un certain nombre de
règles de la manière dont les
subventions peuvent être attribuées il
existe déjà des écrits peut-être est-il
nécessaire de les préciser notamment
quand tu as l'organisation des comités
de sélection quant à l'organisation du
et quand aux mesures qu'il est possible
de mettre en place par l'administration
en matière de contrôle vis-à-vis des
organisations qui sont subventionnées
ceci étant avec ma casquette aujourd'hui
secrétaire d'État chargé de la vie
associative je dirais que c'est une
ligne de crête si je m'extrais du sujet
du fond Marianne parce que la question
de la liberté associative elle me semble
fondamentale et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs l'une des associations que
vous avez auditionnée qui a mis en place
des vidéos contestables et contestées et
que moi même je conteste puisqu'elle
s'en prend à des responsables politiques
Madame la Maire de Paris mais pas
uniquement porte-parole du gouvernement
les intérieurs moi-même prison la
République etc elle invoque me
semble-t-il aussi cette liberté
associative dans les contenus là il y a
une ligne rouge parce qu'on est sur des
contenus politiciens mais jusqu'où
l'administration et même le ministre
est-il fondé à aller dans le contrôle
des productions d'une association c'est
une vraie question c'est pas une
question rhétorique c'est une vraie
question et c'est pour ça que
sincèrement très preneuse des retours et
des préconisations et instructions vous
donnerez à l'issue de cette commission
merci madame la ministre nous allons
conclure donc nous allons prendre deux
questions alors je vais demander aux
auteurs comme d'habitude
d'être trois questions donc rapides
alors Jean-Michel Arnaud Daniel broyer
ministre très rapidement puisque nos
travaux se concluent
je vais essayer de rester finalement
dans les faits vous avez indiqué madame
la ministre en cours d'audition
aujourd'hui je n'ai passé aucune
commande de faire passer le dossier
c'était le premier dossier de l'UFE ppm
ensuite
vous avez indiqué lors d'un communiqué
de presse du 7 avril 2023
que toutes les candidatures reçues dans
le cas de l'appel à projet de fond
Marianne 17 ont été retenus par un
comité de sélection dont le choix s'est
fait via l'administration je vous cite à
la manœuvre dans le respect de toutes
les procédures
enfin cela a été rappelé par le
président le préfet Gravel
a indiqué
confirmer un arbitrage défavorable à
ministre concernant l'association
SOS Racisme bon je comprends la
difficulté du sujet je comprends votre
ligne non pas de défense mais
d'explication ceci étant dit les faits
sont là il y a des contradictions
majeures sur lesquelles effectivement
notre commission à démontrer et à
révéler les circonstances et je pense
que s'il y a un point sur lequel
j'attends au moins en termes de
conclusion de cette audition
des mots de votre part c'est d'assumer
votre responsabilité il y a eu
manifestement des difficultés de gestion
de ce dossier des imprécisions dans la
méthodologie et des implications à
divers degrés y compris politiques sur
la gestion de ce dossier je crois qu'il
serait bien que ce soit dit clairement
ne serait-ce que par respect pour la la
famille de Samuel Paty et pour la cause
que nous défendons nous défendons nous
défendons tout tous ici qui est
effectivement la défense des valeurs de
la République quel que soit le bon ou
séjour je vous remercie merci
Jean-Michel Daniel broyer puis Thierry
cosit merci Madame la Ministre
l'assassinat de Samuel patine nous a
tous bouleversé parce que la République
est ses valeurs sont notre bien commun
j'ai entendu vos propos et je vais
comprendre sur la différence entre le
rôle d'un ministre et le rôle d'un
cabinet ou d'une administration je ne
comprends pas qu'un ministre ne cherche
pas à entraîner la totalité de la
société française sur un combat aussi
symbolique et du coup il y a une
incohérence pour moi qui est le fait que
vous décidiez de retirer enfin vous
n'avez pas dire tiré mais de ne pas
attribuer de subventions à SOS Racisme
et que vous validiez des associations
dans la fragilité est avérée voire qui
sont créés pour ça et et pour le coup
c'est le rôle d'une ministre je pense
que d'entraîner tout et je ne comprends
pas
ce choix merci Daniel Thierry Cosic
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre depuis le début de l'audition
vous nous avez fait état que
vous n'avez pas ou peu participer au
processus de sélection des associations
par contre j'ai noté moi dans vos
réponses incertains de contradictions et
notamment
au moment où vous dites que 300.000
euros et je crois que vous l'avez écrit
c'est trop c'est que factuellement vous
participez à la décision
également l'arbitrage sur sur la
subvention de 100.000 euros pour SOS
racistes
j'ai le sentiment que
dans la sélection des associations c'est
mettre à l'honneur la prise de décision
démocratique la transparence et la
délibération sont des piliers qui sont
me semble-t-il au cœur de votre fonction
à la fois en tant que membre du
gouvernement
luttant contre la défiance
institutionnelle et quand cancienne
ministre délégué de la citoyenneté
cependant et ce sera peut-être une forme
de conclusion comment pouvez-vous ne pas
vous interroger et être alerté par
l'absence de critères explicites de
sélection des associations par voie de
cabinet
j'ai le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans un processus qui s'apparente à une
véritable chimère j'aurais souhaité
avoir votre sentiment sur sur cela
madame la ministre on va vous proposer
également deux éléments de conclusion à
ce stade
du rapporteur et de moi-même et vous
répondrai si vous voulez bien à
l'ensemble sont d'ailleurs avoir à
distinguer tel ou tel mais peut-être sur
le sur les propos généraux et vous
finirez et vous conclurez vous même
madame
oui madame la ministre peut-être pour
faire deux ou trois observations qui se
traduisent évidemment en question
un certain nombre de questions me
semble-t-il même après votre audition
reste en suspens
vous êtes à l'initiative dans les
conditions qu'on a évoqué de la création
de ce fond et vous êtes en vous avez été
en responsabilité de la mise en œuvre
des projets est-ce que à ce stade vous
pensez que le projet devenu fond
Marianne à remplir pleinement ses
objectifs est-ce que vous pensez qu'il a
été à la hauteur des ambitions fortes
affichées et affirmé par le gouvernement
je le rappelle dans un contexte inédit
et particulièrement grave est-ce que
vous considérez que les procédures ont
bien été respectées qu'elles sont
d'ailleurs en tout point conforme à une
gestion saine et rigoureuse des fonds
publics est-ce que vous pensez en
quelque sorte que le fond Marianne a
bien été
utile dans l'expérience nouvelle
de lien porté par les associations
soutenues par le gouvernement pour
lutter contre les discours séparatistes
et permettez-moi madame la ministre
plus personnel parce que je j'ai le
sentiment que vous au long de cette
audition vous vous êtes mise en quelque
sorte en porte-à-faux par rapport au
projet du fond Marianne pourquoi est-ce
que je dis ça c'est parce que vous avez
passé beaucoup de temps
à travers de nombreuses réponses à
expliquer et exprimer que vous vous
étiez tenu à distance
avant
vous êtes toujours à distance vous
n'avez pas d'amis ça j'ai compris que
c'est une réponse à la presse je vais te
dire simplement
au moment de la création du fond
vous le validez puis vous tenez à
nouveau à distance vous ne vous
intéressez pas alors
si vous reconnaissez qu'il y a quand
même eu une intercession
défavorable à SOS Racisme et ensuite il
y a plus de communication
est-ce que je me trompe aurais-je mal
compris
alors dans le même sens de quelques mots
puisque aujourd'hui on est vers la fin
de nos auditions vous le savez madame
même si nous avons comme ceifaoui demain
notamment et votre et Madame bacquesse
cet après-midi mais quand même quelques
quelques moules là aussi et question
donc si on reprend un peu les choses on
voit que nos travaux ont montré qu'il y
avait eu des contacts donc en amont de
la création du fond avec différents
acteurs c'est à dire que l'appel à
projet n'a pas consisté à susciter des
candidatures mais en amont un amant du
fond à préparer des candidatures pour
certains c'est ce qui rend le d'ailleurs
le la notion d'inéquitable tout à fait
juste dans l'appréciation de l'igéa des
associations en ont été sélectionnées
donc quelquefois avant l'ouverture de
l'appel à projet sans prendre de
précoler précautions minimale demande
toujours à une association encore plus
quand il s'agit d'une subvention de
nature exceptionnelle quand on est à 300
350 000 euros c'est exceptionnel dans ce
dans ce milieu
et donc sans aucune garantie les
procédures de sélection ont été à
géométrie variable c'est le moins
compliqué c'est une vision délicate de
manière délicate de dire les choses en
fonction des acteurs
et donc effectivement l'igéa dit des
choses tout à fait claires des décisions
ont été prises modifiées en aval du
comité de sélection donc y compris
directement par vous madame la ministre
sous réserve de vos appréciations bien
entendu et cela nous a été confirmé par
votre directeur de cabinet nous l'avons
dit un appel à projet sans grille
d'analyse sans objectivité
des candidatures
est-ce que vous pensez pas que la
politique de lutte contre les discours
séparatistes méritaient un peu mieux ne
pensez-vous pas non plus qu'une action
qui entendait donc répondre je reviens
au sujet précédent que j'ai déjà traité
un assassinat horrible perpétrer en
octobre 2020 mérité une mise en œuvre
une attention un suivi précis sérieux
continue
au-delà des responsabilités d'un
secrétaire général qui sont pointés par
l'igéa et donc abîmée continuez-vous
vraiment
à dénier toute responsabilité dans ce
fiasco il a fallu que je vous interroge
sur ce point précis pour que vous
connaissiez quelques quelques un bout de
responsabilité
ce fiasco il est dû je dis sophiako
parce que il concerne à travers
finalement l'action de deux associations
qui ont été allés encourager monter
spécifiquement pour cela
finalement
alors que les autres finalement les
autres associations c'était des
associations qui étaient déjà des
associations qui travaillaient avec le
secrétariat général
et donc
finalement tout ce qui a été tenté en
terme innovant entre guillemets ben
c'est cassé un peu la figure alors c'est
dû à la vitesse sans doute à
l'impréparation sûrement à la volonté de
communiquer rapidement c'est une presque
une maladie gouvernementale je parle pas
de ce gouvernement je parle de manière
générale un événement une réponse une
communication c'est vieux comme comme la
politique je suis pas sûr que déjà je
sais pas quoi sous les on retrouvait par
quelque chose de même nature donc c'est
vieux c'est ancien comme méthode de
fermer est-ce que c'est aujourd'hui
pertinent et en s'appuyant sur des
nouveaux acteurs qui finalement ont été
n'ont pas été encadrés
et aujourd'hui d'ailleurs qui sont mises
en cause par cela même qui les ont créé
d'une façon c'est quand même c'est quand
même dur un article 40 pour lui une
demande de remboursement sur quelle base
on sait pas trop mais il me demande de
remboursement à la deuxième
c'est c'est quand même c'est quand même
le signe d'une grande difficulté je l'ai
dit vous auriez pu vous contenter me
semble-t-il d'associer d'amener les
associations déjà connues déjà sur le
terrain à s'intéresser à votre à votre
projet et à développer je pense que le
résultat aurait été sans doute meilleur
et finalement et je reviens à votre
propos introductif lorsque vous avez dit
je salue le travail des de la majorité
des associations qui font un bon boulot
et qui travaillent bien dans ce domaine
etc et je partage je partage votre avis
nous en avons croisé quelques-unes
beaucoup nous a envoyé même leur
production vous voyez de manière à ce
que on puisse regarder concrètement les
choses et il y a des productions qui
sont tout à fait tout à fait
intéressantes à regarder des projets
associatifs tout à fait intéressant mais
finalement en pratiquant ainsi par cet
appel à projet mal géré mal suivi et à
cause de ce projet moi j'ai l'impression
que vous avez surtout fragilisé toute
cette chaîne d'acteurs
qui travaille sur le terrain a dénoncé
des discours des discours séparatifs
depuis des années mais en le faisant
souvent sous l'angle de l'explication du
travail consciencieux sur le terrain de
faire avancer des contribués de lutter
contre le discours séparatisme et qui le
font bien depuis des années et est-ce
que vous avez est-ce que vous avez
conscience que finalement cette
opération on fond Marianne elle
fragilise terriblement cette cette
chaîne de compétences associative qui a
mis du temps à se mettre en place et qui
est une base extrêmement forte et comme
notre collègue le disait il faut pas
jeter tout les bébés avec l'eau du
beurre vous avez repris cette expression
je la reprends à mon compte également
mais malheureusement
le mal est un peu fait même si on espère
que le temps passant on puisse remonter
remonter les choses mais j'aimerais
avoir votre position là dessus madame la
ministre et vous nous répondez vous
concluez en même temps de votre point de
vue combien de temps est-ce que je
dispose monsieur le président
pardon de combien de temps est-ce que je
dispose pour vous répondre
à des questions aussi voilà merci
monsieur le Président d'abord pour vous
répondre au global je redis ce que j'ai
dit depuis le début sur ce sujet c'est à
dire que je prends absolument toute la
responsabilité qui est la mienne c'est à
dire la responsabilité politique je ne
m'en suis jamais dédouanée de cette
responsabilité politique j'ai toujours
assumé qu'elles étaient les décisions
les lignes politiques les commandes
politiques passées je l'ai dit à de
nombreuses reprises pour citer les
grands auteurs à un chef c'est fait pour
chez fait donc Jean d'os bien sûr la
responsabilité de mes décisions mais
aussi de celle de mon directeur de
cabinet qui a délégation de ma signature
avec qui j'ai travaillé en parfaite
symbiose et confiance dans dans les
décisions qu'il a pu prendre en mon nom
il était fondé à cela j'ai dit aussi que
je prenais toute ma responsabilité et
rien que ma responsabilité je ne crois
pas je le redis rapidement mais je le
redis je ne crois pas je suis sans puté
un dirigeant public un responsable
politique la malversation interne d'une
structure à laquelle il fait confiance
au moment il lui fait confiance quand il
n'a pas de raison à ce moment-là de ne
pas le faire je veux dire que sur
l'attribution des subventions et je
réponds je me répète mais je réponds à
une interpellation je redis que je
n'avais pas d'implication personnelle
que je n'ai pas soutenu de dossier en
particulier je le redis très clairement
et que je n'ai pas pris de décision de
soutien à un dossier sur quelques
raisons personnelles que ce soit que
j'ai en revanche rendu un avis quand on
est venu d'initiative me le solliciter
sur la question du suivi je veux dire
que il y a des communications qui sont
adressées c'est à dire des bilans si on
peut dire en conseil des ministres
notamment en février il y en a une qui
est nommée il y a un suivi étroit de ce
dossier ne pas aller dans ligne
générique depuis des subventions et ne
pas contrôler personnellement le travail
mené par les associations ne signifie
pas qu'il n'y ait pas de suivi du projet
je veux dire que tous les mois j'ai
rendu compte de la lutte contre le
séparatisme mais vous avez eu monsieur
présent la gentillesse de le rappeler
que c'est un sujet qui me tient à cœur
de longue date avant même d'être chargé
de la question de la citoyenneté et qui
est un sujet qui pour moi est
intrinsèquement lié à la question de la
liberté des femmes et de la protection
des femmes et on le voit trop souvent
dans trop d'actualités dans le monde à
quel point les femmes sont les premières
victimes de cette idéologie
séparatiste et islamiste qui menace
encore notre sol à leur où nous sommes
en train de parler vous avez fait
mention il a été fait mention et j'en
avais fait moi-même mention de de
l'attentat odieux commis contre le
professeur Samuel Paty j'en garderai
toute ma vie et le souvenir c'est moi
qui ai ouvert la CIC et la cellule
interministérielle de crise et je suis
allée avec le président de la République
et le ministre de l'Intérieur sur place
et tous ceux qui ont été en
responsabilité quel que soit leur degré
de responsabilité au moment d'attentat
terroriste n'oublie jamais ce qu'ils ont
vu senti et entendu sur place quand ils
s'y rendu donc bien évidemment et comme
chacun ici je trouve que c'est une lutte
prioritaire et qui doit continuer bien
sûr d'être mené dans les réponses que
j'ai pu apporter j'ai insisté sur le
rôle que j'avais ou que je n'avais pas
parce que c'est les réponses aux
questions mais aussi parce que j'ai pu
être mise en cause à tort par voie de
presse de fait qu'ici vous n'avez pas
relié bien sûr je distingue les deux et
je n'ai pas voulu répondre à la presse
par l'intermédiaire de la commission
mais j'ai voulu être factuel et clair
pour vous donner tous les éléments sur
sur ces sujets là
[Musique]
je veux redire peut-être parce que on
est passé rapidement sur ce sujet je
suis brève et je le fais vraiment en
quelques minutes mais redire que je n'ai
pas non plus financé de contenu
politique c'est la question n'a pas été
posée j'ai pas financé de contenu
politique en période électorale
contrairement à ce qui a été écrit dans
la presse à un moment il est aujourd'hui
démontré que c'est faux et d'autres
articles sont venus l'infirmer je le dis
parce que quand on est successivement
accusé d'un peu tout et son contraire
dans la presse y compris de délits et
qu'en fait il est démontré semaine après
semaine qu'en fait ce n'est pas du tout
ça la question qui est posée c'est assez
différent que de se demander si un appel
à projet est assez long et assez bien
ficelé ou de se demander s'il y a des
délices sont des choses différentes il a
été soulevé qu'il restait des questions
en suspens c'est juste moi-même je suis
très preneuse d'avoir les réponses des
questions qui restent en suspens je suis
pas omnisciente mais il y a en ce moment
votre commission d'enquête il y a un
deuxième rapport de l'hygia qui arrive
il y a une instruction ouverte du PNF
sur une association en particulier je
n'y reviens pas vous le vous le savez eu
égard la séparation des pouvoirs je suis
pas fondée à commenter cette instruction
qui relève exclusivement de la justice
pour une affaire en cours mais je veux
dire et ce sera ma conclusion qu'il y a
eu cinq mois de travail pour aboutir au
fond de mariage que le l'impulsion
politique qui est donné par nature
contestable nous sommes en démocratie
elle peut l'être elle est et elle a
parfaitement le droit de l'être que la
méthode au-delà de l'impulsion peut
parfaitement être remise en cause et
améliorer et clarifier elle le sera je
n'en doute pas et personnellement quel
que soit les responsabilités que j'ai ou
que je n'ai pas à occuper dans l'avenir
je mettrai en oeuvre les recommandations
qui seront
indiquées en matière de liens sur la
question des subventions et en
conclusion je veux très simplement
redire d'autres l'ont dit je l'avais dit
également précédemment mais je veux
redire et ce sera ma conclusion le
soutien que j'apporte à toutes les
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui des
combattants et des combattantes de la
lutte contre l'islamisme radical en
France et dans le monde toute personne
personnes qui ne serait-ce que prend la
parole publiquement pour contredire et
pour pourfendre l'idéologie de
l'islamisme le fait au péril de sa vie
et on voit bien à quel point aujourd'hui
notamment des lauréats du fond Marianne
qui ont mené une action remarquable et
qui parfois veut une antériorité
d'action de mener bénévolement pendant
des années pour apporter un discours
face à la radicalisation des jeunes le
font aujourd'hui sous le coup de menace
d'insulte permanence de
cyber-harcèlement de menaces pour leur
vie pour leurs proches et je tiens ici à
leur apporter très clairement et très
fermement mon soutien le plus absolu et
le plus inconditionnel je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre merci à vos
collaborateurs et bonne journée à tous